Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 91. Ausgabe.
Und ja, heute wird es total innovativ, glaube ich, denn das ist das Thema.
Innovation, konkreter wollen wir über Sprunginnovationen reden und vor allem darüber,
was das denn nun eigentlich ist und warum die Welt das braucht.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Rafael Laguna de la Vera, richtig?
Richtig, hallo Tim.
Richtig. Hallo, schönen guten Tag, herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist.
Ja, was ist das überhaupt für ein Name, wo hat man den denn her, spanischer Hintergrund?
Ja, man ist in Leipzig in Sachsen geboren und dann heißt man so,
allerdings nur, wenn man einen spanischen Vater hat, der mit meiner Mom, die aus Hamburg kommt, zur Oma gezogen ist,
um Kinderchen, Eierchen zu legen und so bin ich da meine ersten zehn Jahre in der damaligen DDR gelandet.
Okay, in Leipzig?
Also in der Nähe, in Pegau im Süden, in so einem 5000 Seelen Städtchen.
Habe da eine gute Kindheit verbracht.
Wir durften da bleiben, weil drei Jahre vorher mein Bruder Carlos genau am 13.08.61 zur Welt gekommen ist
und meine Mutter als Westdeutsche schon die ostdeutsche Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen musste.
Und so waren wir da so ein bisschen, man kann sagen, gefangen.
Wobei das nicht so ein großes Problem war, meine Urgroßeltern die konnten uns gut aufnehmen,
wir haben da ein gutes Leben gelebt.
Aber irgendwann mal war es doof, die spanische und westdeutsche Familie nicht kennenzulernen
und da hat es mein Vater 74 geschafft, uns dann da rauszuschaffen mit einem holländischen Onkel und einem Peugeot 504,
der schon mit Erdgas fuhr übrigens 1974.
So fluchttechnisch oder?
Nein, das war eine Ausreiseantragsgenehmigung, aber dann holterdipolter.
Dann hattest du nicht so richtig viel Zeit.
Ich glaube, in zwei Wochen haben wir das dann…
Ach so so nach dem Motto, jetzt dürft ihr weg, aber dann auch bitte sofort.
Aber dann bitte pronto, genau so war das.
Verstehe. Und dann ging es wohin?
Dann ging es ins schöne Sauerland nach Bleche, kennt bestimmt jeder, 300 Seelen Dorf.
Klar.
Kennt man von der A45, da geht nämlich eine Autobahnbrücke drüber.
Aber da hatte ich auch eine gute Jugend dann, eine wilde Dorfjugend sozusagen
und habe dann das noch größere Glück gehabt, einen verrückten Onkel in Los Angeles zu haben.
Habe dann quasi so eine zeitlichen Zweisprung gemacht.
Du kamst ja, wenn du in der DDR gelebt hast, hat man so ein bisschen in den 20er Jahren irgendwie gelebt,
wenn ich heute zurückblicke in den Westen 1974 und dann 1976 zum ersten Mal nach LA
und so bin ich dann auch früh mit dem ganzen Digitalkram in Kontakt gekommen,
was man vielleicht mit der Story so nicht unbedingt erwarten würde.
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch meine nächste Frage gewesen, in LA dann?
Mhm /bejahend/, ja, genau.
Also da bin ich quasi jede Sommerferien hin.
Der wohnt im San Fernando Valley, das ist so das Mexican Quarter sozusagen.
Da gab es dann in North Hollywood den Open Bookstore ???,
der dann vollgestopft war mit Computerbüchern, man konnte sich in den VW Bully setzen
und ins Silicon Valley brettern, also der selber hatte alle möglichen Computer,
das war auch so ein Spielkind, bei dem sah es so ähnlich aus wie bei dir hier im Studio.
Gear, gear, gear.
Und dann habe ich damit rumspielen können und hatte führen Zugang.
Zu was genau?
Zu ja Mikroelektronik, würde ich das mal nennen.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen steif, aber damals 4Bit SCM-Mikroprozessoren konnte man kaufen,
Die man sich aber selber zusammenlöten musste.
Dann kam der Xerox Alto, das hatte der dann auch, wo das erste grafische Userinterface drauf war.
Apple II, solche Geschichten hatte der.
Und irgendwann mal hat er mir einen Compaq Portable 1, als der PC dann kam Anfang der 80er Jahre, mitgegeben.
Der kostete damals, ich glaube, 13.000 Dollar oder so was, völlig cracy.
Und dann habe ich den sozusagen auf dem Schoß im Flieger mit nach Deutschland transportiert
und hatte damit Zugang zu diesem Gear und auch zu den Büchern, die ich auch tonnenweise rübengeschleppt habe.
Aber das war ja wahrscheinlich nicht nur Zugang zum Gear,
sondern es war ja im Prinzip auch Zugang zu so einer goldenen im Silicon Valley, so die Zeiten des Homebrew Computer Club,
wo so die frühen Freaks zusammenkamen, unter anderem Steve Wozniak, Steve Jobs etc.,
paar andere Sachen, also sind sehr viele Gründer auch von späteren größeren Firmen waren ja da quasi mehr oder weniger in so einem Club zusammen.
Nicht nur dort, aber auch.
Genau.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen diese Zeit, wie da so die Realität war?
Ich meine, auf der einen Seite dürfte es ja auch noch das normale Laid Back California der alten Zeit…
/unverständlich/
Und auch noch so Hippiezeit gegeben haben.
Wie hat sich da diese elektronische Welt eingeordnet?
Wie sichtbar war das?
Das war nicht sehr sichtbar.
Das war eine verschworene Clique irgendwie, man hat sich über irgendwelche komischen Netzwerke zusammengedialed.
Und sich ausgetauscht, rückblickend sieht man die großen Namen,
das waren aber halt nur Typen, also man wusste ja nicht, wer da ist
und Bill Gates hat da ja auch rumgewurschtelt.
War auch noch bisschen verknüpft mit der Musikszene witzigerweise.
Also viele kamen über Musik, dann kam so Vocoder und dann irgendwie das ist auch sehr artverwandt gewesen.
Man hat sich da keine Gedanken gemacht, das waren Leute, die sich auch mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben,
totales Neuland, also das war irre, man hat da rumgelötet und gemacht und getan.
Das war keine Industrie, die ist ja erst dann danach entstanden.
Und ehrlich gesagt, als ich dann später gesehen habe, dass dieser Bill Gates ein IPO mit Microsoft macht,
dann habe ich mich kaputt gelacht, habe ich gedacht, wie will man denn damit Geld verdienen?
Also falscher kann man nicht liegen.
Weil man einfach gesagt hat, Mensch das ist halt Technik, was soll das sein?
Man hat sich da nicht so Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Aber mich hat das einfach gefesselt, das hat einfach Bock gemacht und so ging es denen, glaube ich, allen auch.
Wie lange warst du da?
Also ich bin wie gesagt von Alter 12 praktisch jedes Jahr in den Sommerferien immer sechs Wochen dahin.
Und zwischendurch mal.
Meine Eltern haben dann noch parallel eine Skateboard-Firma gegründet, weil die haben wir auch importiert aus Kalifornien.
Die erste, California Sun hieß die auch, also die erste Skateboard-Firma Deutschlands ist dabei auch noch rausgedropt.
Ich habe meine Elephant Software, hieß sie, mit 16 gegründet.
Habe Software für die damaligen Mikrocomputer, das war ja vor dem PC,
noch vor den Homecomputern eigentlich, so TRS-80 Model 1, so ein Z90 Rechner.
Für solche Geschichten dann importiert und über das einzige Computermagazin, was es damals gab,
die Chip, mit Anzeigen versickert und dann kam Sinclair ZX80, ZX81,
VC20, dann die Ataris und so weiter, das war so die Zeit.
Also ich habe nie jahrelang in Kalifornien gelebt, weil es mir zwar gefallen hat,
aber ich eigentlich die europäische Kultur immer ein bisschen kuscheliger fand.
Ich fand so diese Roughness, dieses if you don’t make it, dann bist du halt nichts,
das fand ich schon ein bisschen krass.
Auf der anderen Seite hat mich das auch angespornt, einfach mal zu machen.
Also dieser Geist, probiere es halt und wenn es nicht klappt, dann klappt es halt nicht, scheiß egal,
den habe ich schon da mitgenommen.
Und dieser crazy uncle, der immer noch lebt, der heißt auch noch Alf.
Also außerirdisch ist er nicht, aber der hat mich da immer gefördert und inspiriert, das zu tun.
Also habe ich diesen amerikanischen Unternehmergeist und diesen Aufbruch der Digitalindustrie,
die habe ich, glaube ich, da eingeimpft bekommen.
Wo kommt das eigentlich her, dass so dieser American Way an der Stelle so Fehler eher verzeiht?
Kann man das verorten oder ist das einfach so?
Du bist ja schon mehr auf dich selbst gestellt.
Du musst ja sehen wo du bleibst sozusagen und da bleibt dir auch nicht viel anderes.
Weil es sozusagen kein soziales Geflecht gibt etc.
Es gibt kein Netz, keinen doppelten Boden, Ausbildung ist sauteuer,
das heißt, du musst, du kannst dir das im Zweifel gar nicht leisten.
Deswegen ist selfmade auch etwas, also ich auch, ich habe drei Wochen Informatik studiert
und dann hatte ich keine Lust mehr, weil mir das irgendwie nicht spannend genug war.
Solche Sachen sind da eher normal.
Ich meine, wir reden hier Anfang der 80er Jahre, das war total anders, da gibt es jetzt bessere Sachen.
Ich habe da nicht drüber nachgedacht, das war einfach so und so ist es in Amerika auch.
Und wenn das eine nicht klappt, dann machst du halt das nächste und das nächste und irgendwann klappt es.
Weil dir auch nichts anderes übrig bleibt, es muss irgendwann mal was klappen.
Und weil das halt alle machen, ist das eben auch anders akzeptiert.
Total, also dieses, weißt du, ich glaube, der Gedanke, dass man, wenn man es gar nicht erst ausprobiert,
eigentlich schon gescheitert ist, der ist bei uns nicht so drin.
Dieses okay, ich bewege mich halt nicht, ich tue es nicht, weil das ist ja ein Risiko und dann blamiere ich mich.
Könnte ja schief gehen.
Könnte ja schief gehen, aber das ist ja eigentlich ein apriori Scheitern, was ja noch schlimmer ist.
Was hat denn Elephant Software gemacht?
Software verkauft.
Ich bin nach Amerika geflogen, habe TRS-80 Software auf Kassetten gekauft,
habe die nach Deutschland geschleppt im Koffer, irgendwie am Zoll vorbei wahrscheinlich,
soweit ich mich erinnere, habe eine Anzeige geschaltet in der Chip und habe das Zeug verkauft.
Und nachher habe ich angefangen, selber Software zu entwickeln, als der TRS-80,
kennt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr, aber das waren Rechner, die kosteten schon ein paar tausend.
Tandy
Tandy Radio Shack, Turd Shit 80 liebevoll genannt, mit einem Z80 Prozessor, 4K RAM und so huihui.
habe dann selber einen Basic Compiler dafür gebaut, habe dann als die Sinclairs kamen dafür Software gemacht,
weil das dann wirklich erschwingliche Computer waren.
Ich glaube, der ZX80 kostete so 400 Marko der so was.
Das war so ein kleines Plastikbrettchen.
Und damit das Geld verdient, um mir letztlich das Equipment zu kaufen,
weil das ja dann doch insgesamt ganz schön teuer war.
Das habe ich alles so nebenher zur Schule gemacht.
Irgendwo klingelt gerade eine Glocke in meinem Hinterkopf, ich bin …
Ja, du bist alt genug, um das vielleicht gesehen zu haben.
Das war ja so ein bisschen meine Zeit auch, ich habe das ja auch bewusst wahrgenommen,
irgendwo war auch mal was mit Elephant Software, aber das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz zusammen.
Kann gut sein, dass das so eine Softwaredistributionsgeschichte war.
Ja, so würde man es heute nennen, damals war einen Anzeige in der Chip und einen Katalog,
den man noch, meine Eltern sind Übersetzer, die hatten diese automatischen Schreibmaschinen und Kopierer und so was,
dann habe ich wirklich Papierkataloge gemacht und verschickt.
Das war schon wirklich eine interessante Zeit.
Haben wir im Vorgespräch auch schon ein bisschen drüber gesprochen.
So ein bisschen, dass im Allgemeinen von den Jahrgängen, die in den 90er Jahren groß geworden sind,
wird immer so von digital natives gesprochen oder eigentlich auch erst bisschen später.
So die Leute, die dann eben so mit der ganzen Technik groß geworden sind.
Aber es gab die ja in sehr viel kleiner eben auch schon zu dieser Zeit,
die ja gegenüber den späteren Zeiten so ein bisschen den Vorteil hatte,
dass diese ganze Technik noch so überschaubar und so erfahrbar war,
dass da so eine größere Gruppe von Leuten herangewachsen ist, die sich ja jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen auf Rufweite auch immer noch kennt.
Man merkt so, ah okay, die sind da gelandet, die sind da gelandet und so weiter,
die sind immer noch so Teil dieses Gesamtgeflechts und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bilde ich mir das auch nur ein,
aber es war so ein, man hat so ein Gefühl für diese ganze Technik und diese Technikentwicklung gehabt,
die dann so später so ohne weiteres nur schwierig zu erarbeiten war, weil man dann schon so zugeschüttet war,
dann kommt das Internet noch dazu und so und dann wurde es ja auch alles sehr schnell hektisch.
Aber da war auf jeden Fall so eine Generation, die als erstes so ein bisschen das Potenzial gesehen hat
und auch die Auswirkungen, die es auf die Gesellschaft haben kann.
Ja, genau. Wir wurden ja gezwungen, das bis zum Bit runter zu verstehen.
Also meinen ersten Computer habe ich mit 12 zusammengelötet und mit 128 Byte RAM.
Da kanntest du jedes Bit persönlich sozusagen, du hast auch verstanden was eine ALU ist und so was.
Also du konntest schon wirklich im Kopf jedes Bit verfolgen.
Also haben wir, glaube ich, da eine Chance gehabt, noch das Grundverständnis für die Technologie zu entwickeln.
Also ich habe noch irgendwelche ALUs mit CMOS zusammengelötet und so was.
Wenn du das als Fundament hast und dann auf den Softwarelayer gehst,
das war dann alles Maschinensprache mein Basic Compiler, den ich da gerade erwähnt habe,
dann hast du schon ein grundlegendes Verständnis.
Und als dann die ersten Modems kamen und man das nicht durfte und die Post Hackereien und so was und BTX und der ganze Kram.
Ich glaube, wir hatten eine Chance, noch die Black Boxes von innen zu kennen.
Genau und man wurde an diese Magie, die das ja ausstrahlt, herangeführt einerseits.
Aber auf der anderen Seite war es dann für einen auch sofort entzaubert.
Weil in dem Moment, wo man so gesehen hat, ah okay, alles klar,
so auf dem allerniedrigsten Level ist es eigentlich sehr einfach so.
Und diese Folgenabschätzung von Technologie fällt einem ja einfach leichter,
wenn man erst mal weiß, worauf das steht.
Und ich habe oft das Gefühl, es fehlt Leuten so ein bisschen eben diese Verankerung tatsächlich am Boden,
das zu verstehen, um die Implikationen der ganzen moderneren Technologien auch irgendwie richtig einschätzen zu können.
So was alles erzählt wird über was künstliche Intelligenz kann etc. nicht wahr,
da schüttelt man dann vielleicht etwas schneller den Kopf als es andere Leute machen
und das ist auch irgendwie verständlich und das ist auch sehr schwierig, das wieder so herbeizuführen in irgendeiner Form,
so eine Bildung anzubieten, weiß auch nicht ganz genau, ob das überhaupt noch replizierbar ist.
Ja, also ich hoffe, dass wir da noch ausbilden.
Es gibt ja jetzt wirklich gute Ausbildungen, auch gut dank Internetzugang zu alles so ungefähr.
Das stimmt wiederum.
Zum Beispiel gibt es einen Kurs, den habe ich dann später noch mal mir selber reingezogen,
der heißt nand2tetris, können wir gleich mal in den Shownotes hinten dranhängen.
Da geht es wirklich los, dass du mit NANDs anfängst, 1Bit Register zu bauen und so was.
Also so Logikgatter in Elektronik.
Ganz unten und dann baust du Memory, dann baust du eine ALU,
dann machst du deine Maschinensprache drauf, dann machst du eine virtuelle Maschine
und auf der programmierst du dann Tetris.
Also dann kannst du wirklich den Bits zugucken, was die da machen.
Also ist es heute eigentlich fast leichter, an so ein Wissen zu kommen.
Wir haben das noch mit Hardware sozusagen gemacht und auch oft selbst uns beibringen müssen,
weil es gar keinen Zugang zu den Informationen gab.
Das kann man heute schon noch auch machen und vielleicht sogar in kürzerer Zeit.
Würde ich jedem empfehlen, um eben diese Magie rauszuholen.
Absolut, also das ist wirklich der große Sprung, weil da war so diese Bildungslücke,
dass man irgendwie an alles erst mal gar nicht so richtig rankam,
man musste sehr viel lernen, machen, tun, Bücher lesen und mittlerweile ist YouTube so eine unglaubliche Bibliothek für alles mögliche,
muss man halt nur sich auf das richtige stürzen.
Genau, ist vielleicht dann too much.
Drinking from the firehose, also muss man ein paar Pointer haben, wo man reingreifen soll, genau.
Genau, das ist dann…
Genau. So was hatte denn das jetzt für Auswirkungen auf deine berufliche Laufbahn?
Irgendwann war es ja dann vorbei mit Rumspielen.
Ja genau, also meine Eltern haben mich gezwungen/genötigt, noch Abitur zu machen am evangelischen Gymnasium Meinerzhagen.
Weil ich wollte eigentlich, da wollte ich übrigens in die USA, weil da gerade das MIT Media Lab gegründet wurde,
was zwar im Nachhinein dann doch nicht so toll war, aber ich hätte schon Bock gehabt,
da mal ein bisschen länger hinzugehen.
Aber erstens kostete das ein Haufen Geld, ich wusste nichts von Stipendien,
das war mir unbekannt, dass man die sich irgendwie erwirtschaften könnte, also habe ich das gemacht.
Dann zwei Jahre Zivildienst gemacht, nebenher noch mal ein Kino auf und zu gemacht,
also auch mal, weil die starben da gerade, wurden immer zu kleineren Schachtelkinos,
ich fand aber die großen Bildwände toll und richtig dicke Anlage und so.
Da haben wir im schönen Attendorn im Sauerland für sechs Monate im kalten Winter 85/86,
hat uns dann die Heizrechnung gekillt am Ende.
Und abends habe ich dann noch neben dem Zivildienst Geld verdient durch Programmierung an einem kleinen Softwareladen,
den es dann halt in Olpe im Sauerland gab, wo ich Zivi war.
Das heißt, ich war dann auch schon 22, als ich dann schließlich zur Uni Dortmund gefahren bin mit 500 anderen Erstsemestern,
darunter drei Frauen, um Informatik zu studieren.
Ich glaube, das war 85 oder 86 und musste dann feststellen, dass es nicht so wirklich echte Informatik ist,
sondern dass da Matheprofs irgendwie umgeschult haben und dir Calculus 1 und 2 zum 37. Mal beibringen.
Und ich hatte zu Hause 20 Computer stehen.
Also das war dann nicht so mein Ding.
Dann kamen die Olper wieder auf mich zurück und haben gesagt, wenn du dein Studium abbrichst und zu uns kommst,
dann geben wir dir ein Drittel von der Firma, die Firma dicomputer, die es heute noch gibt
und mit der ich auch heute noch was zu tun habe, aber mit Unterbrechungen sozusagen
und bin dann einfach ins Berufsleben reingerutscht, immer so ein bisschen unternehmerisch.
Und habe das dann quasi kontinuierlich gemacht, bis ich dann 95 mal eine Firma an Amerikaner mit verkauft habe.
Dann habe ich mal ein Sabatical gemacht 2000/2001, dann bin ich mal Venture Capitalist geworden
und dann fing eigentlich meine Open-Source-Zeit an, weil das erste Investment, an dem ich involviert war,
war dann die SUSE Linux AG, die Ende 2001 gerade drohte, in den Konkurs zu schliddern,
wie so viele andere Unternehmen nach 9/11, Tech Bubble geplatzt, NASDAQ bei 1000,
kann man sich alles gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, DAX bei 2800, da war ganz schön Asche.
Und habe dann erstens geholfen, dass es die SUSE heute noch gibt, aber vor allen Dingen habe ich mich dann intensiver mit dem Thema Open Source beschäftigt.
Was mich so ein bisschen an diese Homebrew Computerzeiten dann erinnert hat,
wo es eigentlich auch alles Open Source war, bloß nicht so hieß, bis der Bill Gates das so mehr oder weniger beendet hat.
Wir müssen übrigens der Universität Dortmund noch zugutehalten, dass sie ja dann immerhin zum Geburtsort des deutschen Internets geworden ist, Anfang der 90er Jahre.
Aber ich kann das ganz gut nachvollziehen, dass das so in den 80er Jahren einen noch nicht so gerufen hat.
Nein, du sitzt mit 500 Studenten im Hörsaal.
Ging mir auch so.
Da war eine Timesharing Unix Maschine im Keller, da hast du dann von 10-11 Uhr irgendwie deinen Slot bekommen,
da habe ich gesagt, what am I doing here.
Wenn es mal Unix war.
Ja, wenn es mal Unix war, genau.
Okay, also Open Source war sozusagen ein Thema.
Das ist ja so einer der klassischen Träume der Computerwelt.
Das ist so ein Ding, was quasi kulturell mit in die Welt eingebracht wurde, wo es so vorher,
gut, vielleicht gibt es Dinge, mit denen man das jetzt vergleichen könnte, aber dadurch, dass Computer einfach was neues waren,
ist halt auch so diese Vorstellung von Software ohnehin erst mal schwierig bei den Leuten in den Kopf zu kriegen gewesen,
und dann ist natürlich so Open Source oder Free Software, wie auch immer man sagen will.
Also dass sozusagen die Software selber geteilt wird, das Wissen, wie Software dann läuft auf dem Computer,
war in gewisser Hinsicht ja revolutionär so.
Es hat nicht die Welt komplett im Sturm übernommen, aber es gibt ja bestimmte Bereiche,
eigentlich die ganze Software Welt wäre jetzt sozusagen ohne Open Source so auch nicht möglich wie es heute ist.
Welche Bedeutung hatte das für dich und ich meine, SUSE ist ja so eins dieser Unternehmen, die quasi daraus auch hervorgegangen sind.
Ja genau, die gehörten ja zu den Pionieren.
Also wir wären ja bei Weitem nicht da, wo wir sind, das hast du ganz richtig gesagt, wenn es nicht Open Source gäbe.
Trotzdem ist es so, dass die dominierenden Unternehmen meistens Open Source zwar nutzen und auch kontribuieren,
aber ihre Kernprodukte eben nicht Open Source sind, das ist schon ein Interessanter Widerspruch,
warum das eigentlich so ist.
Das heißt, der Traum der Community, dass alles Open Source ist und wir die Freiheiten haben,
die Open Source mit sich bringt im digitalen Leben, die haben sich erst mal so nicht erfüllt.
Das ist auch fast ein bisschen enttäuschend, wenn man darüber nachdenkt.
Aber die ganzen Technologien, die wir jeden Tag nutzen, wären ohne Open Source nicht da.
Ich glaube, das kann man recht einfach sagen.
Also ich da Ende 2001 in die SUSE eingestiegen bin, gingen ja auch die Amazons dieser Welt kurz vor Pleite, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Und die haben dann sehr stark auf Open Source Software gesetzt, erst mal weil sie auch kostenlos wie in Freibier ist.
Frei wie in Freiheit, frei wie in Freibier, das Freibier war ein Element, aber dann haben die gemerkt,
wir können das Zeug dann auch so entwickeln, dass wir Produkte bauen, die man mit proprietärer Software niemals hätte bauen können.
Und so ist Cloud und Hyperscaler und so was entstanden, ohne das hätte es das nicht gegeben.
Nun haben die dann oben den Deckel wieder zugemacht leider.
Das ist nicht unbedingt notwendig, das ist ein Geschäftsmodell, so machen die das halt.
Und so ist das, was wir jetzt als Internet bezeichnen, überhaupt entstanden, das hätte es so nicht gegeben.
Also von daher kannst du sagen, den Wirkeffekt hat es gehabt.
Warum war das so faszinierend?
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass wir alten Computerleute natürlich sehr wissenschaftlich interessiert sind,
und die Wissenschaft selber zur Zeit der Aufklärung, als sie sich erfunden hat, ja auch ein offenes Modell entwickelt hat.
Du stellst eine These, die veröffentlichst du, du veröffentlichst die Ergebnisse, deine Materialien und Ingredienzen,
die du verwendet hast, damit alle anderen, auch deine ärgsten Feinde, das sozusagen nachvollziehen kann.
Das hat schon ziemlich gut geklappt.
Also der ganze Wohlstand, den wir heute genießen, basiert ja auf den Erfindungen der Wissenschaft
und der Umsetzung der IngenieurInnen, die es gemacht haben, das darf man ja nicht vergessen.
Ja.
Und irgendwie, glaube ich, wollen wir das, weil die Digitalisierung dann am Ende ja doch alles durchdringt,
zum einen zum besseren Lernen, zum schnelleren Entwickeln, zum bessern Innovieren,
wollten wir das wahrscheinlich immer in die Digitalwirtschaft sozusagen übertragen.
Ich meine, wir haben es ja selber so gelernt, damals als Autodidakten hast du dir Source Code von anderen Leuten angeguckt.
Wie haben sie es gemacht?
Und wenn der nicht zur Verfügung stand, hast du ihn dekompiliert, annotiert und dann jedem zur Verfügung gestellt.
Was ja auch damals nicht verboten war und auch größtenteils immer noch nicht ist.
Ich glaube, dieser Wissensanhäufungsprozess, ich glaube, der hat uns fasziniert und natürlich auch die damit einhergehende Freiheit,
auf der ja unser ganzes demokratisches System basiert.
Du kannst sagen, Open Source Software ist auch die Chance, dass die Digitalisierung an sich ein demokratischer Prozess bleibt
und nicht in der Hand von ein paar Monopolen ist.
Trotzdem hat sich so Open Source nicht unbedingt überall so durchsetzen können.
Wir haben schon eine relativ starke Dominanz der geschlossenen Systeme, für die ja auch einiges spricht so.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, es gibt nur einen Weg, sondern man muss ja immer schauen, wo ist das.
Aber gerade so im öffentlichen Bereich, über den wir jetzt gleich eh noch mal viel reden wollen,
ist ja das Verhältnis ein bisschen schwierig.
Es gibt auch nicht so richtig eine, wie soll ich sagen, Entwicklungskultur, dass man sagt, okay hier sind jetzt neue Technologien,
die müssen wir für uns urbar machen, wir müssen das jetzt auch selbst lernen und selbst zur Anwendung bringen,
und nicht einfach nur irgendwo kaufen so.
Und das ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, etwas, was spezifisch in Deutschland fehlt,
ist aber auch nicht nur so irgendwie.
Nein, also ich glaube, genau die Ermächtigung des Digitalen sozusagen, geht ja nur über ein grundlegendes Verständnis desselben
und das kannst du halt mit Open Source am besten erlangen.
Deswegen stellt sich für mich eigentlich die Frage gar nicht, wie man es denn machen soll.
Und wenn ein Staat Digitalisierung treiben soll, muss auch Kompetenz bei den Mitarbeitern des Staates da sein, das kannst du nicht outsourcen das Thema.
Und natürlich ist es so, wenn du sowieso Staatsgeld ausgibst, warum soll das Ergebnis dann nicht der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung stehen?
Du hast ja das Geld der Allgemeinheit genommen.
Von daher finde ich auch, dieser Slogan der Free Software Foundation Europe,
public money, public code, der kann wahrer nicht sein.
Das hat dann halt alle Effekte des Selbstermächtigens, des Geldeinsetzens für das Public Good,
dass dann alle was davon haben und natürlich auch die Souveränität in den Systemen, die man dann erzeugt.
Also wenn du durchblickst und dir die komplette Implementierung des Systems vorliegt,
dann bist du auch ermächtigt, dann kannst du entscheiden.
Und das kommt ja aus den USA, ich meine, dort ist es ja in den Universitäten so, dass, wenn an den Universitäten mit dem Geld,
was dann dort investiert worden ist, etwas erarbeitet wird, dann ist es eben auch öffentlich.
Genau. Und übrigens ist es ja mit Forschung immer noch so.
Also wir veröffentlichen die Forschungsergebnisse, das heißt,
jede Forscherin, jeder Forscher kann auf diesem Berg von Wissen aufsetzen und das von da weiter entwickeln.
Warum das mit Software, die öffentlich bezahlt ist, nicht so sein soll, geht mir nicht ein.
Bevor wir zu deinem Engagement in diesem spezifischen Bereich kommen, gibt es ja, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen was anderes zu erzählen.
Du bist Mitgründungsgesellschafter der Code University of Applied Sciences.
Mhm /bejahend/
Was ist das?
Was ist das.
Und wie kam es dazu?
Wie kam es dazu.
Ich habe Tom Bachem getroffen, der der Gründer ist und auch einer der aus der Internetwirtschaft als junger Entrepreneur hervorgegangen ist in Köln.
Der mich von der Idee überzeugt hat, aber eben Geld brauchte.
Und dann habe ich nicht nur selber Geld reingetan, sondern ihm auch noch ein bisschen beim Einsammeln geholfen,
weil er eine neue Art von Universität gründen will, die wesentlich, ich sage mal, mehr Entrepreneurship lehrt.
Die zum einen dir Technologien beibringt, die du auch umsetzen kannst, also wo du Produkte am Ende schaffen kannst.
Also die beschäftigen sich nicht allzu lange mit theoretischer Informatik, sondern da geht es sofort ins Eingemachte,
bei Softwaredesign, bei Design selber, Anwendungsdesign und eben bei der Programmierung.
Die ein tolles Curriculum gebaut hat, um die Leute da schnell reinzubringen.
Und es ist eine Privatuni, die zugelassen ist, das heißt, die Studenten müssen /unverständlich/ bezahlen,
aber die kann man sich sehr schön über EU-Stipendien refinanzieren, ein tolles Programm.
Also das Paket ist einfach toll und wir sind, glaube ich, jetzt im dritten Jahrgang ich sehr erfolgreich.
Also da ist was entstanden, was hoffentlich repliziert wird, weil jeder schreit jetzt nach mehr Programmiererinnen und Programmierern,
die müssen ja irgendwo herkommen.
Seit wann gibt es die jetzt?
Ich glaube drei Jahre. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Wenn man alt wird, dann rutschen einem schon mal ein paar Jahre durch.
Also ich sage mal drei.
Okay. Seit ein paar Jahren gibt es das.
Genau.
Und vielleicht gibt es das auch noch ein paar Jahre.
Wieviele Leute werden da so?
Ich glaube, so um die 500 StudentInnen haben wir.
500?
Mhm /bejahend/
Das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge.
Finde ich einen interessanten Ansatz, weil das touchiert auch das, worüber wir vorhin schon gesprochen haben
und das auch gerade so in den 80ern, wahrscheinlich auch noch in den 90ern, vielleicht auch heute noch
so diese Vorstellung, man müsse jetzt Informatik studieren, um programmieren zu können, also um Software zu schaffen.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, es gibt eine bestimmte Art von Software, da ist das absolut erforderlich
oder sagen wir mal, auch total nützlich, die ganzen mathematischen Grundlagen drauf zu haben,
auch irgendwie den Großteil von wichtigen Datenstrukturen und Algorithmen und so weiter,
was da alles noch mit reinkommt, das erfasst zu haben.
Aber ich auch immer das Gefühl gehabt habe, so Programmieren ist eigentlich was anderes.
Es ist eine Disziplin, die zwar von Mathematik unterstützt und informiert wird, aber nicht im eigentlichen Sinne den Skill unterstreicht,
den die Leute brauchen, die wirklich richtig gut sind.
Also so Leute, die gut programmieren, auch gerne programmieren, haben irgendwie einen ganz anderen Drive
und brauchen eigentlich ganz andere Fähigkeiten.
Ja, also es gibt natürlich eine große Verwandtschaft zwischen Mathematik und Programmierung, den Algorithmen, die man schreibt.
Bei der Mathematik denkst du halt mehr an Formeln in sich abgeschlossenen Systemen.
Das ist eine Überlappung, aber ein anderes Denken.
Ich glaube, dass du ohne Mathematik auch den Zugang kriegen kannst,
dann erfindest du zwar das Rad hier und da mal neu, anstatt den Donald Knuth zu lesen oder so,
aber da kommst du schon auch irgendwann mal drauf, dass man sagt, okay,
ich brauche einen Sortieralgorithmus, dann gucke ich doch mal lieber im Knuth, bevor ich den selber erfinde.
Und gerade jetzt dank Internet mit dem freien Zugang zum Wissen, kann man nach wie vor völlig selbstgelernt sich das Thema reinziehen
und in Onlinekursen bringen.
Wenn man natürlich, was weiß ich, einen Compiler bauen möchte oder eine Prozessoroptimierung oder so was,
da gibt es dann Themen, wo das vielleicht ganz gut ist, eine sehr fundamentale theoretische Grundlage zu haben.
Also Donald E. Knuth oder Knuth, amerikanischer Informatiker, sehr bekannt für sein Buch,
„The Art of Computer Programming“, der ist halt irgendwie da auch dieses berühmte System Tech gemacht hat
und der dafür bekannt ist, keinen Fehler in seinen Sachen zu haben und für jeden…
Wird zum Menschen.
Für jeden Fehler, der gefunden wird, irgendwie Geld auszahlt, aber ist noch nicht so oft passiert.
Ich glaube, er hat jetzt den vierten Band sogar veröffentlicht noch.
Der ist ja auch schon ein paar Tage alt jetzt.
Habe ich nicht verfolgt, aber ist auf jeden Fall lustig.
Aber alle Leute, die ihm tatsächlich mal einen Fehler haben nachweisen können
und da stiegen ja dann sozusagen die Geldauszahlungen immer ums doppelte,
ich glaube, das hat noch keiner eingelöst, also der Gutschein war mehr wert, als das eigentliche Geld.
/unverständlich/
Ja. Genau, also es kann diesen Ansatz geben, aber ich sehe auch, dass es noch andere Fähigkeiten benötigt,
um wirklich Software gut und elegant zu machen.
Und warum ist das wichtig?
Ich denke, wir leiden alle unter schlechter Software.
Und ich persönlich leide extrem unter schlechter Software, weil wenn man halt erst mal wie weiß wie es auch geht
und wenn man dann auch immer irgendwie bei jedem Fahrscheinautomaten, mit dem man irgendwie interagieren muss,
einfach wirklich bei jedem Tastendruck so einen inneren Schmerz, so einen kleinen Tod stirbt so,
wünscht man sich dann halt doch, dass es sich irgendwie doch ändern soll und man fragt sich dann halt auch immer so,
warum ändert es sich denn eigentlich nicht?
Ja, wenn du in Software Engineering reinguckst, ist eigentlich nichts passiert die letzten 30 Jahre.
Also irgendwie wir bauen Software eigentlich immer noch so.
Also das fängt ganz unten an bei den Prozessoren, die immer noch die von Neumann Architektur von vor 75 Jahren implementieren,
die inhärent diese ganzen Sicherheitsprobleme hat.
Also diese ganzen Zero Day Exploids und so was die kommen aus der Architektur.
Da sind wir nicht mehr von runtergekommen, das heißt, da ist eine große Pfadabhängigkeit.
Und in der Softwareentwicklung selber, auch in den Programmiersprachen, die wir verwenden,
kann ich auch nicht so viel brutal innovatives entdecken, was unser Leben da besser macht.
Also sind wir im Grunde genommen noch auf so einer handwerklichen Ebene in der Art und Weise wie wir Software machen.
Und jedes Stück Software ist ein Einzelkunstwerk.
So ein bisschen wie, jeder der mal ein Haus gebaut hat oder so, das sind immer Prototypen im Grunde genommen.
Deswegen ist dein Fahrkartenautomat ein Prototyp, deine App ist ein Prototyp.
Es ist schon ganz schön schlimm.
Das ist übrigens wahrscheinlich auch einer Gründe, warum die geschlossenen Systeme,
wie iPhone oder so was iOS, gewisse Vorteile mit sich bringen, weil du kannst halt da innerhalb deiner Organisation für gewisse Strengheit sorgen,
in der Art und Weise wie du das tust.
Wenn du das komplett offen entwickelst, ist das ein bisschen schwieriger durchzusetzen.
Das könnte man natürlich durch bessere Prinzipien, besseres Engineering machen, aber da sind wir irgendwie noch nicht.
Also irgendwie Softwareentwicklung ist noch keine Wissenschaft.
Ja. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob es das unbedingt werden müsste, ob das so wissenschaftlichen Prinzipien wirklich folgt.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, so gute Softwareentwicklung mogelt sich irgendwo so dazwischen durch.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch so …
Nein, weißt du was das glaube ich ist, jeder kennt das, es gibt halt diese Wahnsinnsprogrammiererinnen und -programmierer.
Da kennt jeder zehn Stück von, wo du so sagst, alter Gestalter, die programmieren hundert an die Wand alleine.
Ja.
Die haben irgendeine Idee und dann sind die drei Tage weg und dann kommen die raus und sagen, hier ist fertig.
Und dann guckst du dir das Ding an und sagst,…
…was zur Hölle.
…was zur Hölle, was tun wir hier eigentlich?
Die sind ein bisschen zu selten, also das ist noch ein bisschen Magie, das sind so unsere Zauberer.
Das stimmt.
So, aber nach all diesen ganzen Unternehmungen und Gründungen und Business bist du jetzt in die,
ja, jetzt hätte ich fast Politik gesagt, dem Staat beigetreten in gewisser Hinsicht.
Es gibt jetzt eine Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovationen, mit der schönen Abkürzung SPRIND.
Wieso gibt es die, was ist da passiert, was macht die und was ist deine Rolle da?
Die gibt es, weil die Expertenkommission 2016 der Kanzlerin, die legt jedes halbe Jahr einen Bericht vor,
wie man Innovation besser fördern könnte als Staat seit vielen vielen Jahren.
Hat 2016 der Kanzlerin empfohlen, eine Agentur nach dem Vorbild der amerikanischen DARPA,
der Defence Advenced Research Projects Agency, zu gründen.
Die das Internet erfunden haben.
Genau, das hieß mal ARPAnet aus gutem Grunde, die ein resilientes Netzwerk bauen wollten.
Irgendwie hat es ja scheinbar geklappt, ich glaube, die haben sich nicht vorgestellt, dass das mal so skaliert.
Aber noch viele andere Dinge.
Also wenn du dein Mobiltelefon anschaust, das ist GPS, Touchsscreen, die ganze Sensorik, die da drin ist,
das sind alles DARPA-Projekte.
Und übrigens MRNA-Impfostoffe sind auch 2011 von der DARPA mitgefördert worden.
Also auch eine Curevac und eine Biontech hat von denen Geld bekommen vor zehn Jahren, also mit weiser Vorausschau.
Das hat der Eisenhauer 1958 im Sputnikschock gegründet, weil er gesehen hat,
dass trotzdem es Amerika wahnsinnig gut ging in dieser Zeit, und die auch viele Industrien entwickelt haben
und ein großer Wohlstand war, haben sie das Spacerace irgendwie verpennt, trotzdem seine Ministerien eigentlich genug Geld hatten.
Und da hat er gesagt, irgendwas geht hier schief und was ging schief, die interdisziplinäre Entwicklung von Technologien ging schief.
Und deswegen hat er die DARPA und die NASA gleichzeitig gegründet, um das Spacerace sozusagen ernsthaft anzutreten,
richtig zu funden und die zu entfesseln von der Art und Weise wie Ministerien arbeiten müssen.
Bei DARPA, das D steht für Defence, was viele Leute immer ein bisschen verstört nachvollziehbarerweise.
Aber ich glaube, der wichtigere Buchstabe ist das erste A, das Advanced, also dass es jetzt hier nicht nur so um Forschung geht,
sondern dass man schon explizit Sachen anstrebt, die irgendwie beyond sind so.
Und ich meine, Internet ist vielleicht wirklich das beste Beispiel, ich meine, es gibt ja viele Verschwörungstheorien,
was sozusagen der Grund war, aber man kann, glaube ich, festhalten, im wesentlichen ging es darum,
sie wollten halt irgendwie ihre Forschungsstandorte miteinander vernetzen, weil macht ja auch Sinn
und das halt dann irgendwie mit Computern und daraus ist dann eben genau das ARPAnet und später eben dann auch das Internet dabei rausgekommen,
weil es halt einfach so advanced war, dass anderen Leuten jetzt auch nichts besseres eingefallen ist
und es ja auch interessanterweise das Internet dann so viel Dynamik auch entwickelt hat,
dass es ja sogar den privaten Initiativen von Microsoft, Compuserve und so weiter, also es gab ja verschiedenste Vorstöße
und verschiedenste Ideen, ich glaube, Bill Gates hat noch Mitte der 90er Jahre davon geträumt,
irgendwie diesen Bereich auch noch zu übernehmen, musste dann aber sehen so, ja nein funktioniert nicht,
weil das Internet eben auch durch Open Source, aber nicht nur, aber eben durch seine eigene Dynamik hier vorangeht.
Also das ist so ein bisschen die Legacy von DARPA.
Und sehe ich das jetzt richtig, dass das jetzt quasi so ein bisschen auch so eine Gedankenvorlage ist, aber ohne den Verteidigungsaspekt?
Genau, man hat dann 2017 in den Koalitionsverhandlungen festgelegt, dass man das zivile und das militärische teilt,
also abtrennt, wobei das hat man eigentlich gar nicht gemacht, sondern man hat das Zivile,
das bin ich, Agentur für Sprunginnovation, SPRIND und eine Cyberagentur gegründet,
die aber nur für Cybersicherheit da ist.
Das heißt, eine rein militärische SPRIND die gibt es gar nicht.
Das muss man auch noch sehen.
Warum man jetzt ausgerechnet Cybersicherheit abtrennt, ist auch noch mal eine andere Frage.
Also das ist ja mindestens Dual Use in den Zivilbereich herein auch so.
Aber so sei es, ist ja vollkommen okay.
Wir sind auch jetzt vom Charakter sehr sehr unterschiedlich in der Struktur, die wir geschaffen haben.
Also die Geschichte geht dann so weiter, dass es in den Koalitionsvertrag ging,
wird ja auch gerade ein neuer verhandelt, also das war jetzt quasi der letzte.
Dann hat man versucht, ein Design, eine Struktur zu entwickeln, das hat dann zwei Jahre gedauert,
bis man so einigermaßen wusste, was man wollte, hat da eine Kommission einberufen.
Da bin ich dann berufen worden, das war das erste Mal, dass man mich in irgendein Bundesministerium gecalled hat, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe davor eigentlich öffentliche Behörden vermieden, weil die meistens Finanzamt oder so hießen,
mit denen du als Unternehmer zwar zu tun hast, aber nicht unbedingt freiwillig.
Und habe halt meinen Input geliefert, wie meines Erachtens so eine Agentur aussehen sollte.
Wer hatte denn da deine Telefonnummer?
Ja, wer hatte meine Telefonnummer, das war der Kommissionsleiter, der Dietmar Harhoff,
der ist am Max-Planck-Institut für Innovationsforschung in München.
Der hatte von mir gehört aufgrund meiner Open Source Aktivitäten.
Ich hatte ja nach der SUSE-Zeit dann die Open-Xchange gegründet
und mich sehr für das Offenhalten der großen Internetprotokolle, Email, DNS und so weiter engagiert.
Ich glaube, die brauchten halt einen Digitalisierungsmenschen da drin, der irgendwie Ahnung hat.
Und da haben sie mich ausgesucht.
Dass der mich dann unterwegs fragt, ob ich den Job nicht machen will, hat mich total überrascht.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, habe ich mich erstens nicht gedanklich damit vorher beschäftigt,
zweitens auch nicht gedacht, dass irgendwie, wenn man eine Bundesagentur gründet,
dass da so ein Typ wie ich überhaupt gefragt wird und fühlte mich natürlich gebauchpinselt, muss ich auch ehrlich sagen.
/lacht/ Kann man aber jetzt bei, wo sehen Sie sich in zehn Jahren, war es nicht auf der Liste.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich fand es immer cool, mich aus meiner Comfortzone rauszubeugen, das war natürlich super reizvoll.
Weil da hatte ich mal so gar keinen Plan von der öffentlichen Seite,
aber das ist eben der Unternehmergeist, ich glaube, das reizt einen dann,
da ins unbekannte Land vorzudringen.
Und dann habe ich, obwohl die OX damals schon 300 Mitarbeiter hatte und so,
das war schon, da mal eben zu sagen, ich jetzt nicht mehr…
OX ist die Open-Xchange
Open-Xchange. Da gehst du mal eben raus, das machst du natürlich auch nicht so leicht.
Aber ich war da jetzt zwölf Jahre und ich glaube, der Open Exchange tat das dann auch gut,
dass da mal jemand anders weitermacht und habe mich daraus verabschiedet
und habe dann am 01. Januar 2020 quasi erst mal halbtags und im Juni dann ganztags den Job übernommen.
Also so alt sind wir jetzt noch nicht wie es klingt, wir sind also, je nachdem wie man zählt, knapp zwei Jahre da.
So Bundesagentur klingt jetzt erst mal nach Behörde, aber es ist, glaube ich, rein technisch eine GmbH?
Ja.
Die aber dem Staat gehört.
Ja, 100 Prozent.
Zu 100 Prozent.
Und was ändert das, also ist ja jetzt erst mal nur so irgendeine GmbH.
Ja.
Die ist nicht gemeinnützig, sondern das ist einfach so eine normale?
Das ist eine normale, aber dadurch dass der Bund 100 Prozent Eigner ist, ist es natürlich irgendwie gemeinnützig.
Okay.
Wir sind der Bund.
Ja, also es gibt ja auch ein steuerrechtliches gemeinnützig.
Das brauchen wir nicht sozusagen.
Ja, das ist nicht erforderlich.
Gut, ich frage mich halt einfach nur, warum ist das jetzt überhaupt die Struktur
und wofür soll die jetzt konkret genutzt werden?
Also die Ziele, die festgelegt worden sind, in letztlich der Gründungskommission und vorher in dem Koalitionsbeschluss,
sind basierend auf der Feststellung, dass wir in Deutschland zwar ein tolles Wissenschaftssystem haben,
tolle Erfinderinnen und Erfinder, tolle Erfindungen machen, wir haben eine tolle mittelständische Wirtschaft,
aber die letzten 75 Jahre leben wir von den Sprunginnovationen von vor 100-120 Jahren.
Also chemische Industrie, Pharmaindustrie, Automobilindustrie und so weiter.
Und die ganzen neuen Themen, da haben wir zwar miterfunden fleißig, aber die Industrien sind woanders entstanden so.
Speziell bei den Computern.
Ja. Da kann man es mal so richtig dran ablesen.
Genau, weil das macht man sich, glaube ich, auch nicht klar.
Also schon noch in den 70er Jahren gab es so diverse deutsche Unternehmen, welche die man noch heute kennt,
Siemens war da sehr unterwegs, Nixdorf natürlich, mit eigenen Computersystemen, mit eigenen Betriebssystemen,
mit eigenen Softwaresystemen, was gab es noch, CTM, kennt auch heutzutage kein Mensch mehr.
Und das ist dann alles abgeräumt worden noch in den 80er Jahren.
Und es ist genau gar nichts übrig geblieben.
Du kannst sogar noch vorher anfangen.
Also wir streiten uns ja, immer wer gewinnt schreibt die Geschichte.
Also die Amerikaner erzählen ja die Geschichte, dass der ENIAC der erste Digitalcomputer war,
ich glaube, das ist nicht wahr, ich glaube, der Konrad Zuse hat das erste Ding gebaut.
Ja.
Zwar noch mit Relais und nicht mit Röhren, aber so be it.
Das ist dann so der Spin so, mit den Röhren war das so.
Dann war das irgendwie digitaler, was natürlich Quatsch ist.
Also das war, wann war das denn, ich glaube, Mitte der 40er Jahre, ich glaube, der hat noch im Krieg angefangen.
Und der Konrad Zuse war ja sowieso ein übrigens absolut interessanter Mensch,
auch ein Universalgenie, hat da ordentlich vorgelegt und auch in vielen anderen Gebieten noch,
Aber daraus ist dann keine Industrie entstanden.
Der Heinz Nixdorf war noch einer dieser Gründerunternehmer, ist dann auf der Cebit tot umgefallen auf einer Party,
das war sehr schade, aber da ging es eigentlich schon bergab,
weil die Amerikaner mit dem PC, der dann quasi für so eine Standardisierung im Mikrocomputerbereich gesorgt hat, abgeräumt hat.
Da sind wir am Ende leer ausgegangen, da haben wir nichts mitgenommen.
Und diese Erkenntnis, dass das ja alles gut und schön ist und es ja eigentlich auch gut geht,
aber wie ist es denn in zehn oder 20 oder 30 Jahren?
Auf welchen Sprunginnovationen basiert denn dann unser Wohlstand?
Wir sehen ja, dass jede Industrie irgendwie angegriffen wird auch durch die Digitalisierung.
Dass neue Technologien häufig nicht von den Großkonzernen, die in dem Bereich tätig sind,
auch wirklich in Einsatz gebracht werden, weil man in so tiefen Pfadabhängigkeiten mit den alten Technologien steckt,
dass man das Neue erst mal gar nicht wahrnimmt und dann drüber lacht, so nach Gandhi,
und es ignoriert und so weiter, bis dann der Herr Tesla in Grünheide eine Factory hinbaut
und man sagt, ups jetzt wird es aber Zeit, dass wir uns mal bewegen.
Und die Pfadabhängigkeit war halt der Verbrennungsmotor, weil wir haben ja so viel Knowhow und deswegen wollen wir Verbrennungsmotoren bauen und so.
Das heißt, also auch unsere Kernindustrien sind nicht unbedingt in 100 Jahren noch so da oder in 50 oder in 30 oder vielleicht sogar in 10.
Und das haben wir schon an einigen Bereichen gesehen.
Zum Beispiel waren wir ja im Mobiltelefonbereich durchaus führend in Europa.
GSM haben wir hier erfunden und Firmen wie Siemens und Nokia waren die Weltmarktführer in diesem Gebiet.
Bis man im Grunde genommen einen höher gegangen ist und gesagt hat, telefonieren ist nur eine App.
Wir legen das jetzt auf IP, also aufs Internet sozusagen und bauen tragbare Internetgeräte
und der Controllpoint ist das Betriebssystem auf dem Telefon.
So und zack waren Nokia und Siemens raus aus dem Business und eine Apple und eine Google räumt das Feld da ab.
So passiert Disruption und das geht in ein paar Jahren, wenn man nicht aufpasst so.
Das heißt, wir müssen das ändern, wir müssen jetzt sehen, dass wir nicht nur tolle Sachen erfinden,
sondern dass wir diese tollen Erfindungen, die dann Sprunginnovatgionspotenzial haben,
dann auch translatieren in volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen und dahinter hängt auch irgendwo der wirtschaftliche Nutzen.
Wobei da war der Erfolg in der letzten Zeit auch nicht so gut.
Ich meine, mit der Solartechnik ist ja auch was gelungen gewesen und auch im Windbereich
und das hat ja dort schon in den letzten Jahren eigentlich auch die Waffen gestreckt und gesagt,
so nee, lass mal die Chinesen bauen.
Ja, da haben wir uns an die Wand subventionieren lassen sozusagen.
Also die Chinesen haben halt kein Beihilferecht.
Das heißt, die haben ganz einfach gesagt, gut, Solarpanels, Deutschland gibt das Geld raus und kauft wie blöde,
kann natürlich nicht so günstig produzieren wie wir, und damit wir in den Markt kommen,
subventionieren wir halt die Industrie bis die andere Industrie platt ist.
So das ist so ein typisches Plattformmodell, wie wir das ja heute sogar in Internetcompanys wie Uber oder so was sehen,
die dann solange Milliarden Venture Capital reingekippt kriegen, bis der Wettbewerb nicht mehr mithalten kann
oder Lieferando oder so was.
Starbucks.
Starbucks genau, das sind alles Dinge, da machst du halt so lange externes Kapital rein, damit du Preisdumping machen kannst,
das ist es ja letztlich, bis die anderen nicht mehr können und weg sind und dann bist du Monopolist.
Aber ich würde das jetzt auch nicht so sehen, dass das jetzt nur sozusagen von außen verschuldet war.
Nein, gar nicht.
Also erst mal noch mal zu Solartechnik, immerhin haben wir der Welt einen Gefallen getan.
Durch unseren Push da rein und das Umleiten des Geldes ist die Industrie so attraktiv geworden,
dass so eine Art Moore's Law ja auch bei den Solarpanels angefangen hat
und jetzt ist das Zeug so billig, dass man es nicht mehr subventionieren muss.
Also man kann sagen, das ist ein Erfolg und eigentlich sollte Deutschland sagen, sind wir nicht toll.
Das Blöde ist halt bloß, dass die Industrie hier nicht ist.
Das liegt noch an vielen anderen Faktoren, das ist klar, so einfach ist das nicht,
da können wir auch nachher noch drüber reden, das hat auch was mit Kapitalmarkt zu tun und Zugang dazu.
Das hat was mit der Professionalisierung in der Industrie zu tun, wie arbeiten Startups mit den Platzhirschen sozusagen zusammen.
Aber es hat eben auch was damit zu tun, wie staatliche Subventionierung funktioniert.
Denn dieses Kapital muss irgendwo herkommen, wenn es nicht aus dem Kapitalmarkt kommt, muss es vom Staat kommen,
dann hast du ein Wirtschaftsversagen, dann muss es vom Staat kommen.
Aber es muss auf eine Art und Weise kommen, was Wettbewerb inzentiviert.
Wir subventionieren häufig so, dass wir Wettbewerb im Grunde ausschalten.
Und mit der schönen warmen Fördermilch, wie wir das intern bei der SPRIND ab und zu nennen, es uns gemütlich machen.
Das darfst du nicht machen, du musst natürlich und das machen die Chinesen sehr gut,
du musst den Wettbewerb aufrechterhalten.
Das heißt, auch die, die da Staatsknete kriegen, müssen im Wettbewerb mit anderen zeigen, dass sie es können.
Den Eindruck hat man nämlich oft, dass so Sachen gefördert werden als Zukunftstechnologie
und dann wird da so viel Geld reingesteckt in wenige Unternehmen, die dann sagen, naja also so richtig viel bewegen müssen wir uns jetzt nicht.
Also es ist ja, wenn man sich den Prozess anguckt, wie das geht, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Konjunkturprogramm 5G
oder ein Konjunkturprogramm Quantencomputer oder so ausgerufen wird,
dann gibt es einen Prozess, bis sich die Ministerien einig sind, wer wieviel Geld bekommt
und dann geht das in das normale Projekt und Zuwendungsantragsgeschäft rein.
Was sehr ritualisiert ist und sehr komplex und sehr langwierig.
Weil wir wollen ja kein Steuergeld verschwenden, deswegen müssen wir mindestens 500 Seiten Formular machen
und das dauert dann halt mal ein Jahr oder anderthalb, bis das ausgefüllt ist und genehmigt ist.
Dann wird eine Bonitätsprüfung der Zuwendungsempfänger gemacht, dann scheiden alle kleinen Firmen aus,
weil die einfach die Bonität nicht haben, also müssen Konsortien gebildet werden, die von großen Unternehmen geführt werden.
Und so und damit fließt das Geld eigentlich immer in denselben Flusslauf, da ist kein Wettbewerb.
Da müssen wir mal drüber nachdenken, ob das so richtig ist.
Diese Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovation, also Sprunginnovationen, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wann gibt es diesen Begriff?
Der ist damit erfunden worden, glaube ich, fast.
Also man kann, ich wusste mal, wer den zuerst genannt hat, aber der ist noch nicht alt.
Aber deutsche Sprache mächtige Sprache, wir können ja einfach Substantive zusammensetzen,
zur Abgrenzung eben von Innovation, weil wir nicht so genau wissen, wieviel Sprung schon in dem Wort Innovation steckt,
haben wir es einfach davor gestellt.
Okay, aber was es meint ist einfach eine Innovation, die einen gewissen Mindestsprung macht sozusagen,
also diesen Schritt macht von permanenter inkrementeller Verbesserung, die man sonst irgendwie immer sieht
hin zu so einer disruptiven Art der Innovation, die also die Kraft hat, bestimmte andere Märkte soweit in Eigenschwingung zu bringen,
dass sie so ein bisschen vor sich hin zerbröseln.
Das ist immer Teil davon, also Sprung, im Englischen übersetzt nennt man das ja auch disruptive Innovation
und in „Disruption“ ist auch irgendwas zerstörerisches drin, das geht ja schon auf Schumpeter im Grunde zurück.
Aber ehrlich gesagt leben wir jetzt schon in anderen Zeiten als der Schumpeter mit seinem Degen.
Es geht immer darum, dass man hinterher merkt, im Leben der Menschen, auf Fotos sieht,
in Wirtschaftskreisläufen nachschauen kann, dass diese Sprunginnovation stattgefunden hat.
Also ein Bild von einer Stadt vor und nach dem Auto ist eine ganz klare Socke.
Es entstehen häufig Wirtschaftskreisläufe, die so nicht vorgedacht sind.
Also zum Beispiel so eine Tourismusindustrie ist wahrscheinlich auf dem Rücken des Autos entstanden, dass man nach Italien tuckern konnte.
Und zack hast du Tourismus.
Das sind sicherlich nicht Dinge, wo Herr Daimler drüber nachgedacht hat, als er das Auto erfunden hat.
Deswegen weiß man immer auch erst hinterher, ob was eine Sprunginnovation war.
Aber man kann ein paar Parameter entwickeln, die so Sprunginnovationen gemein haben,
um sozusagen das Sprunginnovatoinspotenzial abzuwiegen und das ist eigentlich unser Job.
Dass wir solche Dinge finden, dass wir sie inkubieren, dass wir ihnen dann nicht nur das Geld geben,
sondern auch die Zeit und ei Connections sozusagen ins Netzwerk, um diese Dinge mal zu probieren.
Und wenn man dann genug davon macht, so die These, dann wird das ein oder andere Ding dann auch klappen.
Was bedeutet das jetzt konkret für diese Bundesagentur?
Die ich mir jetzt irgendwie die ganze Zeit versuche als Firma vorzustellen, mir das aber noch nicht so richtig gelingt.
Also hat man da irgendwie einen anderen Modus als jetzt in einem anderen Unternehmen?
Jain, also wir versuchen, nach vorne raus sozusagen, also hin in die Welt,
im Grunde genommen wie ein Startup zu wirken, also sehr zugänglich zu sein,
keine großen Hürden aufbauen mit Formularen und Gedöhns, sondern über die normalen Medien erreichbar.
So dass jeder, der meint, er hat da eine Sprunginnovation am Wickel, hat 20 Jahre jetzt im Keller verbracht
und jetzt, wenn er nur, dann wäre, dass die auf uns zukommen.
Dass die Leute, die in den wissenschaftlichen Institutionen sitzen, sagen, ich habe jetzt hier zehn Jahre geforscht,
jetzt gibt es keine Projektförderung mehr, aber wir könnten hier richtig was draus machen, dass die uns leicht finden.
Das ist uns auch gelungen, wir haben über 700 Projekteinreichungen Stand heute gesehen,
wovon auch zehn durchaus ernstzunehmendes Sprunginnovationspotenzial haben, davon haben wir so 25 jetzt anfinanziert,
wir inkubieren das, wir nennen das Validierungsphase, da können wir auch schon mal 100.000-200.000 Euro reintun relativ schnell,
um uns die Zeit zu kaufen, mit den Leuten dann das Projekt zu entwickeln.
Und wenn es uns dann noch immer gefällt, können wir 5-10 Millionen im Jahr in solche Projekte reingeben.
Das haben wir jetzt für fünf Projekte auch schon beschlossen und werden jetzt hoffentlich im November das sechste beschließen,
was wir da tun.
Das ist schon eine neue Art.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass, wenn man Steuergeld ausgibt, man natürlich gewissen Regularien unterliegt.
Wir haben uns da Regeln gegeben, die uns sehr sehr starr und steif machen
und die sicherlich auch mit ein Grund dafür sind, dass wir da nicht schnell genug in Sachen reingesprungen sind
oder auch gewisse Entwicklungen in der Wirtschaft nicht schnell genug erkannt haben und eingeschritten sind,
um zum Beispiel so was wie die Solarpanelthematik hier bei uns zu halten.
Das ist der zweite Teil der Arbeit in der Agentur, dass wir an diesen Instrumenten arbeiten, an uns selber.
Also ich mache immer den Scherz, die erste Sprunginnovation der Agentur Sprunginnovation ist die Agentur für Sprunginnovation,
weil wir einfach Dinge anders machen müssen.
Und wir haben das jetzt auch genau formuliert und hoffen, dass die neue Regierung das auch mit ins Programm aufnimmt,
dass wir da ein paar Fesseln abgenommen bekommen und so schneller werden können.
Die Vorbildorganisation DARPA, ich habe mal eine Ex-Direktorin gefragt, was ist denn eigentlich das Feature von euch,
das Hauptfeature und da hat sie gesagt, Geschwindigkeit.
Von Erstkontakt bis Geld auf dem Konto ein Monat ist immer unser Benchmark gewesen.
Das ist echt flott.
Und das heißt, wir müssen nach hinten hin einen Apparat bauen, der jetzt erst mal mit den jetzigen Strukturen klarkommt.
Des öffentlichen Steuergeldes aufgeben.
Wir müssen natürlich, wir geben Steuergeld aus, also müssen wir uns auch anstrengend, nichts zu verschwenden,
aber gleichzeitig müssen wir ja Risiken eingehen und auch zulassen, das mal was scheitert.
Das ist schon ein Widerspruch in sich, den wir da auflösen müssen und dann müssen wir natürlich die ganzen Verfahren machen,
die halt üblich sind, wenn man das tut.
Also haben wir hinten einen Verwaltungsapparat, der quasi die Maschine der Ministerien bedient des öffentlichen Raums
und nach vorne haben wir unsere InnovationsmanagerInnen, derer sind das jetzt sieben an der Zahl,
die aus bestimmten Fachgebieten kommen, die für bestimmte Themen brennen,
die ein Netzwerk von Leuten mitbringen, um bestimmte Themen zusammenzubringen und zu entwickeln,
die Projekte zu sichten, die werden unterstützt von AnalystInnen, auch so zehn an der Zahl und Projektmanagern,
die die unterstützen bei der Entwicklungsarbeit sozusagen.
Weil wir ja durchaus auch inkubieren und echte Firmen starten sozusagen oder eben in bestehende Firmen reingeben und die dann die Projekte überwachen.
Das sind so 20 Leute ungefähr und dann haben wir hinten noch mal 15, die sich um den ganzen Verwaltungsapparat,
ums Marketing und PR und so kümmern, das heißt insgesamt sind wir eigentlich nur 35 Leute, das ist nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Aber wenn man das vergleicht mit meinetwegen Venture Capital Firmen, die im privatwirtschaftlichen Bereich unterwegs sind,
ist es trotzdem viel und das liegt daran, dass wir eben eine größere Verwaltung hinten haben müssen.
Wenn wir das jetzt weiterentwickeln, können wir weitere Werkzeuge wie zum Beispiel die SPRIND-Challenges bauen,
das ist eigentlich unser erstes neues Werkzeug, was wir jetzt gerade an den Start geschoben haben,
wo wir top-down ein Thema vorgeben.
Alles andere ist ja mehr so bottom-up, man reicht Ideen rein, die InnovationsmanagerInnen die haben schon auch ihr Ding
und drehen das, das ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen mehr proaktiv, aber das Thema Challenges, da sagen wir,
was sind denn die großen Fragen der Zeit, die wir lösen wollen?
Die erste Challenge hat sich um das Thema antivirale Wirkstoffe gekümmert, also nicht Impfstoffe, sondern Wirkstoffe.
Also wenn der Virus mal drin ist.
Da haben wir im Juli ausgerufen, wer Ideen hat, wie wir ein Breitband antiviralen Wirkstoff schaffen können,
eine Art Penicillin gegen Viren, der möge bitte einreichen.
Der Call hat knapp zwei Monate gedauert, also haben wir den Leuten Zeit gegeben, ihre Einreichungen zu machen,
die wir auch sehr stark gecoacht haben, also das war sehr viel Interaktion mit insgesamt 60 Teams, 45 haben eingereicht.
Vor zwei Wochen hatten wir die Jurysitzung, wir haben neun Projekte ausgewählt, von denen jeder so roundabout 700.000 Euro fürs erste Jahr bekommt
und den Mittwoch danach, also zwei Werktage später hatten die den unterschriebenen Vertrag auf dem Tisch.
Also da waren wir mal wirklich schnell, weil wir ein Instrument gefunden haben, mit dem wir schnell sein können.
Wir haben dann bei der Verkündigung der Gewinner jetzt bei der Falling Walls gerade auch gleich die nächste Challenge ausgerufen,
da geht es um Carbon Capture und Utilization das heißt also nicht nur CO2 rausholen,
sondern aus dem CO2 irgendwas wertvolles machen, so dass die Gesamtkosten des CO2 Captures runtergehen
oder vielleicht sogar auf 0 oder vielleicht sogar Profit machen, das wäre natürlich noch toller,
weil dann brauchen wir nicht mehr diskutieren, wer es bezahlen soll.
Also zumindest sollte es der Preis des Capturens auf dem Niveau der CO2-Zertifikate sein,
wo immer die landen, was immer eine Tonne CO2 kosten wird, wenn wir das dafür rausholen könnten, wird es ein Nobrainer.
Und so werden wir jetzt so alle zwei, drei Monate, denke ich mal, neue Challenges starten,
die dann auch sehr schnell Geld in solche innovativen Themen reindrücken können.
Und die laufen dann über mehrere Jahre.
Nach einem Jahr machen wir einen Cut und gucken mal, wir selektieren die Gewinnerteams und dann geht es ins nächste Jahr,
whatever it takes, um das fertig zu machen.
Wenn man jetzt solche Challenges ausschreibt, muss man ja dann auch schon in etwa einen Themenbereich ansprechen.
Und das heißt, man muss sich ja vorher dann auch sicher sein, dass das quasi jetzt auch eine wertvolle Geschichte ist.
Jetzt weiß man ja oft bei den großen Disruptionen auch gar nicht unbedingt vorher, wo das ist.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass hier eine riesige Gefahr lauert, wie das wahrscheinlich bisher oder generell für die Politik ein Problem ist.
Ich will es mal so als Buzzword Resilienz nennen, die für meinen Geschmack nicht ausreichend ausgeprägt ist.
Das heißt, es werden irgendwelche Sachen gehypt und das ist dann irgendwie die Zukunft.
Ja, was weiß ich, hatten wir schon, künstliche Intelligenz so als superschwammigen Oberbegriff,
wo dann irgendwie alles mögliche drunterfällt oder was halt so derzeit so ein bisschen die Krankheit ist,
irgendwie so dieser ganze Blockchain-Wahnsinn.
Wie macht ihr das, dass ihr euch davon freihaltet, also wie wählt man quasi diese Themen aus?
Weil das erfordert ja schon eine gewisse Kompetenz und eine gewisse Wachheit auch in der ganzen Debatte um solche Themen.
Wie stellt ihr euch da auf, um da auf die richtigen Pferde zu setzen?
Wir haben sowohl für die Auswahl und Inkubation der Projekte als auch für die Themen der Challenges einen Katalog erarbeitet.
Das sind sieben Oberkriterien, so 90 Unterkriterien ungefähr, die wir rückwärts rausgefiltert haben,
um mal zu ermitteln, was waren denn eigentlich die erfolgreichen Sprunginnovationen, was charakterisiert die.
Der letzten 10-20 Jahre?
150 Jahre.
Aha.
Hat sich nichts dran geändert oder sogar 500 Jahre.
Wenn du hier das Buch, was ich mit dem Thomas Ramge habe, liest, da haben wir Gutenberg als Beispiel.
Das war ein Sprunginnovator, der hatte auch einen Finanzier an der Seite und die Typen sind da genauso gewesen wie heute.
So ist zum Beispiel eine der sieben Kategorien die Innovatorin oder der Innovator, der Typus Mensch, der das macht.
Also wir schauen darauf, ist das jemand, der für das Thema brennt, der Wirkung erzielen möchte und der möglichst ein nützliches Thema am Start hat,
komme ich gleich noch mal drauf.
Denn wenn du dir die Leute anschaust bis hin zu einem Elon Musk oder so, den Leuten von heute, das haben die alle gemeinsam,
total wirkungsorientiert, super Nerds in ihrem Thema, haben sich da 10-20 Jahre reingebaggert in dieses Zeug,
haben richtig Plan davon, sind natürlich auch meistens ziemlich intelligent, das heißt,
die können dieses Wissen auch aufnehmen und verwerten und dann kreativ zu was neuem formulieren.
Und wenn du allein solche Parameter hast und die sitzt dann den Leuten, die die Themen einreichen gegenüber,
hast du ein Stück strukturiertes Handwerkszeug, um zu evaluieren, ob das was werden könnte oder nicht.
Anderes Thema ist der ganze Plattformgedanke.
Es ist häufig so, dass Erfindungen eine Idee haben, was sie eigentlich machen wollen, aber das machen die dann am Schluss gar nicht.
Da wird sich fünfmal gedreht und man macht dann am Ende was ganz anderes.
MRNA ist so eine Plattform, man wollte eigentlich Krebs heilen, macht man vielleicht auch noch,
oder zumindest wirksame individuelle Krebstherapien bauen und dann kommt der Herr Coronavirus daher
und man sagt, oh upsala, das ist mit der Technologie können wir auch damit was machen.
Und dann drehen die sich auf der Hacke rum, so wie das Biontech und Curevac gemacht haben
und können in kürzester Rekordzeit einen Impfstoff entwickeln.
Das heißt, wenn du eine Plattform hast, musst du weniger Zukunftsvorhersage betreiben, die sowieso schwierig.
Wenn man es nicht macht, kann man die Zukunft nicht vorhersagen und wenn man es macht, ist es keine Zukunft mehr.
Also ist es gut, wenn man sagt, wir haben eine Plattformtechnologie, die auch noch in ganz andere Anwendungsbereiche sich reindrehen kann.
Wobei es ja bei Biontech eben genauso funktioniert hat, bei Curevac wiederum gescheitert ist.
Genau, Gott sei Dank hatten wir zwei Chips auf dem Tisch oder drei mit Moderna.
Eigentlich hatten wir zehn auf dem Tisch und ich sage mal, zwei haben es dann wirklich geschafft.
Wobei die Unterschiede marginal sind, aber eben dann doch ausschlaggebend.
Also wenn es Biontech auch nicht geschafft hätte, dann würden wir jetzt alle mit Curevac-Impfstoff rumlaufen,
weil es dann der beste wäre, den es gibt, auch nicht so schlimm, weil der hätte auch uns zumindest vor den ganz fürchterlichen Auswirkungen geschützt,
nur eben nicht so stark vor Infektion.
Aber war nicht notwendig, weil Biontech war schneller.
Aber das Projekt hieß intern übrigens Project Lightspeed, das sagt eigentlich alles.
Dass man so ein Projekt machen kann liegt daran, dass vorher eine Plattform da war, die man so drehen konnte.
Wenn man also drauf achtet, dass irgendwas eine Plattformtechnologie ist, dann kann man zwar sagen,
wir versuchen jetzt das damit zu erreichen mit der Technologie, aber ob das dann da rauskommt ist dann ein bisschen egal,
weil mit der Plattform kannst du andere Dinge tun.
Es gibt natürlich auch die ganz …
Um Technologiefolgen gleich mal mit vorzudenken, sind auch die SDGs, diese Sustainable Development Goals Teil des Parameterkatalogs.
Wir achten darauf, dass auf keinen Fall negativ eingezahlt, dass wir also nicht eine Technologie entwickeln,
die einfach unseren Prinzipien, die wir uns da gegeben haben, nicht mehr entsprechen.
Und im gewünschten Falle natürlich da positiv drauf einzahlen.
Das heißt, also nicht jede Innovation ist eine gute Innovation für die Menschen.
Und um zu sagen, hallo wir sind der Bund, wir geben Steuergeld aus, also es muss letztlich bei den Menschen ankommen was wir machen,
größtmögliches Glück für die größtmögliche Anzahl von Leuten schaffen sozusagen, Bentham
Kannst du mit den SDGs ganz gut abwiegen.
So und von der Sorte sieben Kategorien, 90 Parameter, darauf kannst du Projekte legen, aber darauf kannst du auch Themen legen für Challenges.
Und so wird man sich dann relativ schnell einig, was eigentlich die großen Fragen der Zeit sind, wir top-down stellen wollen,
wie jetzt antivirale Wirkstoffe, CO2 Capture und von der Sorte wird es noch ein paar mehr geben,
da ist man sich dann relativ schnell einig.
Also es ist auch überhaupt nicht jetzt so auf Digitalisierung konzentriert, sondern es geht eigentlich um alles?
Ja, genau.
Also alles was das Leben der Menschen besser macht und was die Antworten auf die großen Fragen der Zeit hat.
Und Digitalisierung ist sicherlich so was Kampfklasse 30 Prozent der Projekte, die wir sehen.
Aber 30 Prozent sind Energie und Umwelt und 30 Prozent sind Biotechnologie und Medizin
und dann 10 Prozent sozusagen der ganze Rest.
Also es ist schon, passt irgendwie zu Deutschland, würde ich sagen,
weil am Ende musst du ja auch was entwickeln, was du skalieren kannst.
Und da liegen sicherlich unsere Stärken oder unsere größten Lücken, irgendwie in der Digitalisierung.
Wobei auch da wir bei der Digitalisierung …
Übrigens ein Parameter, das wollte ich noch erwähnen, ist der Antihypeparameter.
Also ist das ein Hypethema, was wir hier gerade sehen?
Und da versuchen wir, nicht mitzuspielen.
Also wir haben keinen Quantencomputerinvestment im Augenblick, wir haben keinen KI-Investment, wir haben kein Krypto-Investment.
Wir gucken uns das trotzdem an, weil oft ist das so, wenn der Hypecycle, wenn du da mal durch bist,
dann kommt dann ja doch was, was spannend ist, aber wir sind nicht, wenn der Hypecycle oben ist, mit dabei.
Das machen wir einfach nicht.
Ja, das kann ich nur unterstützen.
Weil ich habe so den Eindruck, dass ist so ein bisschen die Bananenschale, auf der Deutschland auch gerne ausrutscht.
Also das ist gerade der zurecht beklagte Gesamtzustand der Digitalisierung, hat ja auch viel mit so einem Mangel an Vorstellungskraft zu tun auf der einen Seite,
dass man einfach die Chancen davon nicht gesehen hat, natürlich hat man dann in der Öffentlichkeit auch immer so eine Risikodebatte,
aber am Ende werden die Chancen einfach nicht ausreichend genutzt und da geht es irgendwie nicht so richtig voran.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, das Land steckt da auch wirklich in einer Schleife fest, wo es so recht nicht rauszukommen vermag.
Ja, also das hat, glaube ich, viele Gründe, aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass gerade die Buzzword politisch gut verarbeitbar sind.
Weil die hat dann schon jeder mal gehört irgendwie.
Und dann kann man halt in einem Satz sagen, wir machen jetzt irgendwas, Quanten, KI, 5G, Blockchain, you name it
und dann finden das alle toll, dass man das macht.
Ob eine Technologie jetzt kurz vorm Sprung ist oder nicht, das ist schon ein schwieriges Handwerk, das überhaupt zu ermitteln
und ist dann zum Beispiel als 2012 die DARPA in MRNA investiert hat und die Firmen gefördert hat,
hatte keine Sau eine Ahnung, was MRNA-Wirkstoffe überhaupt sind.
Das ist halt kein Hype.
Deswegen muss man den Organisationen, die solche Dinge aufspüren und fördern sollen, da auch die politische Freiheit geben.
Also sprich, nicht politisch reinwirken, jetzt macht mal Quanten und KI, sondern macht mal Sprunginnvotionen.
So übrigens auch geschehen, also das muss ich wirklich sagen, das ist auch gelungen, dass wir als SPRIND da politisch unabhängig sind.
Und auch manchmal Sachen sagen dürfen, die politisch mal so gar nicht gern gesehen werden.
Wir argumentieren da rein sachlich.
Also die Agentur ist ja trotzdem angeschlossen an das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung
und ich glaube, auch Wirtschaft und Energie heißt das, glaube ich, gerade.
Mhm /bejahend/
Wie verteilt sich das?
Also wie kann man an zwei Ministerien angeschlossen sein, ohne dass die sich dann permanent dabei stören?
Da möchte ich jetzt nichts zu sagen.
Nein, also historisch ist erst mal das Bildungsministerium federführend beauftragt gewesen, die Struktur der SPRIND zu überlegen, wie man es macht.
Das ist ja schon immer alles ein bisschen kompliziert.
So das hat man dann zwei Jahre lang gemacht, dann gab es die Gründungskommission,
wo allerdings sowohl der Vertreter des Wirtschafts- als auch des Bildungsministeriums saßen.
Dann haben wir im Januar 2020 angefangen und sind im Grunde erst mal gebootstrapt worden vom BMBF,
aber dann kam das BMWI aktiv dazu.
Im Augenblick ist die Arbeitsteilung so, dass die Challenges vor allen Dingen auf der Seite des BMWI jetzt stattgefunden haben
und die eigentlich Projektfinanzierung aus den Töpfen des BMBF kommt.
Wobei man muss dazu sagen, da wir viel neu machen, haben wir es auch noch immer mit dem Finanzministerium
und dem Bundesrechnungshof zu tun, weil wir, wenn du neue Instrumente schaffen willst, muss man halt vom BMF eine Genehmigung bekommen,
die natürlich den Bundesrechnungshof fragen und so weiter.
Was so ist wie es ist, aber nicht gerade schnell.
Also die Entwicklung der Instrumente, die hat uns eigentlich am meisten Zeit gekostet und wir sind noch lange nicht fertig.
Also wir wünschen uns jetzt, dass in den Koalitionsvertrag reinkommt, dass es auch Gesetze gibt, die geändert werden,
dass wir da anders arbeiten können und haben das auch sehr konkret vorgeschlagen was das ist,
haben das auch untersucht und rechtlich abgesichert und so weiter, um einfach die SPRIND an sich selber weiterzuentwickeln.
Um sie auch vielleicht direkt mit der hoheitlichen Aufgabe zu beleihen, also nicht als Unterauftragnehmer der Ministerien,
sondern die SPRIND ist halt dazu da, Sprunginnovationen zu finden und zu fördern und zu finanzieren und so weiter.
Macht das mal und dann sagt ihr uns, wie ihr es denn machen wollt und dann lassen wir euch das machen
mit einem mehrjährigen Haushalt, damit wir nicht irgendwelche Dezemberfieber entwicklen müssen
und noch die Kohle raushauen müssen, was totaler Quatsch ist, das tun wir auch nicht,
aber das Geld ist dann halt weg nach den klassischen Haushaltsregeln und man hat es nicht zum Einsatz gemacht.
Also wenn der Bund sagt, wir wollen aber, dass ihr das macht und wir wollen so viel Geld da hinlegen,
dann soll es auch mal eine Zeit lang da liegen bleiben, damit wir das dann sinnvoll zum Einsatz bringen können.
Und zwar in dem Moment, wo man es braucht.
Genau. Und auch in dem Moment mal was abbricht, wenn man gemerkt hat, dass man gescheitert ist.
Und das passiert nämlich häufig nicht, weil es eh egal ist.
Weil wenn du eben einen jährlichen Haushalt hast und du brichst ab und zahlst das Geld nicht mehr, dann verfällt es am Ende des Jahres.
Also ist die Motivation das zu tun auch sehr gering.
Das ist nicht gut.
Denn noch mal DARPA-Mensch gefragt zum Scheitern, wird man ja häufig gefragt, keiner will scheitern,
aber wenn man sich das Scheitern nicht erlaubt, dann probiert man auch nichts aus, dann ist man schon gescheitert.
Der hat gesagt, scheitern ist total okay, was nicht okay ist, ist nicht zu wissen, wann man gescheitert ist.
Weil dann musst du auch aufhören, wenn deine These nicht mehr stimmt.
Aus vielen Gründen, das hat Opportunitätskosten, wenn du es weiter machst und es kostet auch Geld.
So und das ist schmerzhaft, das tut keiner gerne, das kennt jeder aus seinem Privatleben,
dass man noch mal drei, vier Jahre, was weiß ich, in eine Beziehung, in ein Investment, in irgendwas investiert hat,
obwohl man eigentlich schon wusste, dass man gescheitert war.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade kein gutes Metathema ein, um mal so ein Beispiel vielleicht zu erarbeiten, wie das so laufen könnte.
Nehmen wir mal an, ich bin jetzt in irgendeinem der Themen, die jetzt als Challenge rausgegeben sind, was ist da jetzt gerade so aktuell noch,
außer den Medikamenten und dem Carbon Capture?
Ja, wir haben jetzt, also die aktuelle Challenge, wo der Call bald rausgeht, ist die Carbon Capture und Utilization Challenge,
aber du musst ja nicht an einer Challenge teilnehmen.
Wenn du irgendein Thema hast, von dem du glaubst, dass das Sprunginnovationspotenzial hat…
Challenge ist mehr so ein, hör mal, das Thema haben wir auf der Kette, irgendwie wenn ihr da jetzt mit reinkommt,
dann steigt sogar noch die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Genau.
Aber ich kann jetzt auch irgendeine ganz grandiose Überlegung haben, so mit Podcasts die Welt heilen oder so
und dann könnte ich halt einfach vorbeikommen.
So und dann schaut mich erst mal einer streng an und sagt, okay erzähl mal, wir gucken was da dran ist.
Also du gehst auf unsere Webseite SPRIND mit Dora Punkt org und da steht Projekt einreichen.
Da stellen wir dir 12-13 Fragen, so ein bisschen als Reflexion für dich, ob du wirklich an einer Sprunginnovation dran bist.
Weil natürlich ist jeder Innovator stolz auf das, was er oder sie macht, man ist dann sehr verliebt darein,
aber wenn es dann eben ein neuer Verschluss für einen Plastikbeutel ist, dann ist das vielleicht eine Innovation,
aber wahrscheinlich keine Sprunginnovation.
So und das versuchen wir, vorher ein bisschen im Selbstfindungsprozess durch das Beantworten dieser Fragen zu erwirken.
Das schickst du uns und du schickst uns, was immer du an Unterlagen zu deinem Projekt hast, formlos, einfach her damit.
Dann melden sich Leute aus unserem Analystenteam.
Das heißt, dann wird dann erst mal geguckt, in welchen Bereich fällt das rein und dann sucht man sich die passende Person raus.
Genau, und wenn wir die nicht haben, dann heuern wir eine Expertin von draußen, wo wir ein tolles Netzwerk aufgebaut haben,
weil alle finden irgendwie die SPRIND gut und haben auch Bock uns zu helfen,
so dass wir wirklich auf ein fanatisches Netzwerk da zurückgreifen können.
Tun wir meistens nachgelagert auch noch, weil wenn dann ein Projekt wirklich entwickelt wird,
dann ist es immer gut, die mit hinzuzuziehen, auch um Kapazität zu schaffen, um andere Blickwinkel drauf zu bekommen.
Aber da werden sozusagen auch Leute dynamisch reingeholt.
So nach dem Motto, okay da haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht im eigenen Team die entsprechende Kompetenz aufgebaut,
dann wird einfach der Telefonhörer in die Hand genommen und gesagt, so hier.
Genau, Liste runter, haben wir dafür schon einen ausgewiesen?
Nein, Recherche, welche gibt es, her damit, manchmal auch gleich zwei.
Also ist das sozusagen auch wirklich eine Initiative, um eine Vernetzung mit existierenden Expertenwissen in der Gesellschaft vorzunehmen,
die jetzt gar nicht in irgendeiner Form staatlich aufgehängt ist.
Ja, absolut.
Und die können auch herkommen wo sie wollen.
Es ist nicht immer so, dass wenn eine Expertin sagt, das ist nicht, dass wir das dann auch finden,
da muss man aufpassen bei Sprunginnovationen.
Wenn sie nicht ein bisschen crazy sind, dann sind sie keine Sprunginnovationen, Zitat Einstein Ende, glaube ich so ungefähr.
Also man muss da aufpassen.
Wir haben natürlich mit den jetzt sieben Innovation ManagerInnen, die wir haben, also da ist so Durchschnittsalter eher 60,
die haben schon ihr Ding im Leben gemacht, da sind schon ein paar echt abgefahrene Typen dabei.
Wir haben auch in dem Expertenkreis so ein paar Nobelpreisträger, Superunternehmer,
also da sind schon paar richtig heiße Typen drin, mit denen wir da arbeiten können.
So die schauen sich das an, wir legen das auf den Kriterienkatalog, es gibt ein paar schnelle Ausschlusskriterien,
also wenn Primary Use militärisch ist, dann sind wir halt einfach nicht zuständig, das machen wir nicht.
Das geht dann in ein Board rein, in internes Board, welches die sich dann anschaut.
Das ist voll digitalisiert, also das Board ist erst mal ein Jira-Board, was abgearbeitet wird.
Da fliegen schon eine ganze Menge raus, die einfach aufgrund der Kriterien ausscheiden.
Und die, die wir diskutieren wollen, gehen dann wirklich in ein Gesprächs-Board rein.
Da treffen wir uns alle zwei Wochen und diskutieren diese Themen.
Und wenn wir sagen, das könnte was sein, dann kommen die Analysten zurück,
die kommen auch zwischendurch mal gerne mit Fragen zurück und sagen, wir haben noch ein paar große Fragen,
wir wissen, dass das Geld kostet, die zu beantworten, das Geld würden wir dir gerne in Form eines Validierungsauftrages geben,
hast du Bock?
So und das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Das dauert dann manchmal zwei Monate, manchmal sechs, manchmal acht,
je nachdem wie schnell die Teams dann auf der andern Seite sind.
Wir bringen die dann mit anderen Leuten zusammen, um sie zu unterstützen, zu coachen, das fehlende Wissen reinzuholen,
Zugang zu irgendwelchen Forschungsinstituten und Leuten, die dort sind.
Und mit dem Ergebnis, dass da so eine Art Exposé rauskommt, was wir dann unserem Aufsichtsrat vorlegen,
der so halb Verwaltung, Politik und halb Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft besetzt ist.
Da sind also Vertreter der Ministerien drin, MDBs, aber eben auch eine Susanne Klatten, Peter Leibinger von Trumpf,
die das aus der wirtschaftlichen Seite betrachten oder eben jener Dietmar Harhoff, der mal die Gründungskommission geleitet hat.
Die schauen, ob wir uns an unseren eigenen Prozess gehalten haben.
Also die sagen jetzt nicht, wir finden das Thema gut oder schlecht, die lassen sich im Thema natürlich ausbilden und sind sehr interessiert daran,
aber die Themenauswahl obliegt uns.
Sie schauen nur, ob wir uns vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel ins Projekt verliebt haben und uns nicht an unseren eigenen Prozess halten.
Da geht es ja auch um Gleichbehandlung und solche Geschichten.
Und wenn die dann nicken, haben sie jetzt fünfmal gemacht, dann wird in der Regel eine Tochter GmbH gegründet,
das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, wegen Beihilferecht und allem möglichen, das wollen wir allerdings ändern,
die dann eine Forschungskooperation mit dem Unternehmen der Erfinderinnen und Erfinder eingeht.
Also wir machen dann so einen Zweisprung mit dem Geld.
Brauchen wir gar nicht so tief drauf eingehen, ist ein bisschen furchtbar, aber ist halt so, das ist das technische Mittel.
Aber da gehen dann in die GmbHs 5-10 Millionen pro Jahr ist so die Durchschnittszahl,
die dann die Forschung und Entwicklung für das, was wir da machen wollen, bezahlt für ein paar Jahre.
Na ist ja schon substanziell.
Ja, das ist richtig Geld, genau.
Also wir werden dieses Jahr, keine Ahnung, ich muss wirklich raten, das können wir sicherlich genauer sagen,
aber 50-60 Millionen werden das sicherlich insgesamt sein dieses Jahr.
Jetzt kennt man das ja aus den USA, ist ja so ein Engagement in solche Innovationen auch durch privates Geld,
durch Venture Capital und andere Investitionsformen gedeckelt, das scheint in Deutschland auch nicht so richtig zu greifen.
Inwiefern kann denn da die Wirtschaft oder diese Finanzierungswirtschaft eigentlich einen Beitrag zu leisten?
Der Finanzierungskreislauf in Deutschland und Europa ist kaputt.
Wir haben, das liegt wohl auch noch am Zusammenbrechen des Neuen Marktes und der Finanzkrise,
wir haben ja nie eine Aktienkultur entwickelt und daraus resultiert verdammt viel.
Wenn du rückwärts rechnest quasi vom Börsengang, gibt es ja da vor verschiedene Finanzierungsphasen
und Investorinnen und Investoren, die da Geld reinlegen und jede Phase muss ja auch einen Exit haben.
Das heißt, die müssen aussteigen können die Investoren, hoffentlich mit Profit und dann kommen die nächsten rein.
Bis zum IPO und dann kann jeder rein und raus wie er will, dann ist es eine öffentlich gehandelte Firma.
Also du kannst mit einer mittelgroßen Tech-Firma keinen IPO machen in Deutschland oder Europa.
Also selbst eine Biontech und Curevac sind an der NASDAQ an die Börse gegangen in New York,
weil hierfür die Liquidität nicht da ist.
Es gibt wenig vorgelagerte Venture Capital Fonds, insbesondere in den späten Phasen, weil da wenig Geld reinfließt,
weil die US-amerikanischen besser performen, weil sie eine bessere Börse haben, in der man dann den nächsten Schritt gehen kann.
Und das kannst du rückwärts entwickeln.
Das Marktversagen hat der Bund schon vor 12-13 Jahren festgestellt und hat, zumindest für die sehr frühen Phasen,
den HighTech-Gründerfond ins Leben gerufen, die sogenannte Seed und Series A Finanzierungen machen.
Am Anfang war das bis zu einer halben Million, ich glaube, die können jetzt bis anderthalb Millionen in eine Frühphase in Unternehmen geben.
Man hat mit dem Zukunftsfond noch mehr Geld ins privatwirtschaftliche Venture Capital gegeben,
aber wir sind so Faktor fünf, sechs, sieben pro Kopf kleiner als eine USA.
Daran, dass das in den USA anders ist, ist übrigens auch eine DARPA „mit schuld“.
Denn was die virtuos machen meines Erachtens ist zum einen, mit der DARPA-Zuwendung, mit dem Geld, was die DARPA selber verteilt,
das sind immerhin 3,5 Milliarden im Jahr mittlerweile, die gibt es auch schon bisschen länger, deswegen sind die auch auf Flughöhe,
aber das ist ja schon mal viel Geld, das wird eingesetzt, um die frühen Technologierisiken zu finanzieren.
Also wenn was aus dem Labor kippt und so Grundlagenforschung, Physik funktioniert oder Chemie oder whatever,
jetzt müssen wir das ja bis es ein Produkt wird noch über viele Schritte bringen und das kann ganz schön lange dauern.
So wie autonomes Fahren oder MRNA-Wirkstoff hat ja auch über zehn Jahre gedauert.
Das finanzieren die, aber gleichzeitig haben die auf der anderen Seite den Staat als Auftraggeber als Instrument.
Das heißt, wenn daraus droht, wirklich ein Produkt zu werden, wird häufig ein Einkaufsauftrag gezielt in diese Unternehmen gegeben.
Das heißt, die Technologierisiken sind so langsam abgearbeitet, das Auftragsbuch ist voll, was passiert?
Private Investoren kommen natürlich rein, weil die sagen, links ist save, rechts ist save, der Gap ist nur noch so viel,
das Risiko ist überschaubar, rein.
So dann sind die Fonds natürlich auch erfolgreich, das funktioniert einfach, das ist Risikokalkulation.
Und damit ziehen die natürlich auch immer mehr Privatinvestoren an, weil die über Jahrzehnte hervorragende Returns für die produziert haben.
Und übrigens die meisten vermögenden Deutschen legen in US-amerikanischen Fonds ihr Geld an, weil es da einfach funktioniert.
Da ändert sich ein bisschen was, jetzt europäische Venture Fonds sind so seit fünf Jahren auch durchaus erfolgreich.
Man hat den Zukunftsfond geschaffen in der letzten Regierung und der wird sicherlich weitergeführt in diese Regierung,
es gibt jetzt auch eine SPRIND, die jetzt auch anfängt zu arbeiten.
Ich denke, als wichtigstes nächstes Instrument müssen wir jetzt noch die Einkaufspower des Bundes und der Länder und Kommunen steuern.
Dass wir sagen, wir müssen vergaberechtlich in der Lage sein, Innovationsfinanzierung durch gezielten Einkauf zu machen.
So wie das ja unter anderem auch in der Raumfahrt in den USA ja stark funktioniert, SpaceX ist auch deshalb so groß geworden,
weil eben dann eben auch sehr viele Aufträge für Satellitenstarts etc. vom Staat kam, auch zu anderen Tarifen,
nicht unbedingt zum niedrigsten Preis und ja der Lohn der Arbeit ist dann letzten Endes, dass man es halt geschafft hat,
innerhalb von zehn Jahren mit einem einzelnen Unternehmen im Prinzip die komplette Raumfahrt …
… auf links zu krempeln.
Aber total.
Ja und das werden wir noch erleben, wenn Starship funktioniert.
Starlink.
Nicht Starlink, nee.
Ach so das große Starship.
Also die dicke Rakete.
Die dicke Rakete.
Die dicke Rakete, die den Preis pro Kilo, den du in den Weltraum schießt, irgendwie auf zehn Dollar runterbringt,
so dann geht es zur Sache.
Nein genau, die haben sogenanntes pre-commercial Procurement gemacht, das heißt, die kaufen Produkte, die es noch gar nicht gibt.
Da legt die NASA Mal eben 2,6 Milliarden hin und sagt, bau mal trallala.
Und dann kannst du natürlich was machen, dann geht es ab.
Übrigens dieses pre-commercial Procurement ist auch das Prinzip, was wir bei den Challenges anwenden.
Technisch kaufen wir, bestellen wir ein Produkt, was es noch gar nicht gibt, wir sagen, macht mal einen antiviralen Wirkstoff breitbandig.
Und das ist wirklich ein Verfahren, was wir da verwenden, das gibt es schon seit 2008 in der EU,
ist in Deutschland ein einziges Mal angewandt worden und dann nie wieder.
Das Wirtschaftsministerium hat uns darauf aufmerksam gemacht und ausgebildet, die haben sogar Leute, die echt gut sind,
die dir erklären wie das geht und wir haben gedacht, wir gucken nicht richtig.
Hier liegt ein wirklich agiles Instrument rum, es hat nur noch keiner verwendet, deswegen sind wir echt froh, dass wir das gefunden haben.
Das machen wir jetzt in klein bei den Challenges, so eine NASA macht das natürlich mit anderen Zahlen,
aber why not, das können wir auch mit anderen Zahlen, also nicht wir SPRIND, aber der Bund oder die EU kann das auch mit anderen Zahlen machen.
Stichwort Europa.
Jetzt ist das alles so eine deutsche Geschichte so und klar, in Deutschland lohnt sich das insofern, als dass es eine starke Wirtschaft ist
und viele Leute hier leben etc., aber jetzt wissen wir ja auch, einerseits muss es ja auch rechtlich innerhalb vom europäischen Kontext funktionieren,
auf der anderen Seite denke ich mal, dürfte es ja auch in anderen Ländern vergleichbare Ansätze und so Weckrufe geben.
Also gibt es da überhaupt erst mal eine europäische Dimension in dem Ganzen?
Gibt es Kooperationen, gibt es ähnliche Agenturideen bereits in anderen Ländern?
Und lässt sich da in irgendeiner Form auf einer europäischen Ebene zusammenarbeiten?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist unglaublich logisch, dass so was ja letztlich auf einer europäischen Ebene stattfinden muss.
Trotzdem finde ich es gut, dass die Bundesregierung beschlossen hat, wir machen jetzt einfach mal los mit der SPRIND
und in der Tat sind wir die ersten in Europa, die da am Start sind.
Werden aber ständig angesprochen von anderen europäischen Ländern, wie macht ihr das, sollen wir das auch machen und so.
Das erste mittlerweile nicht mehr EU-Land war die UK, die gerade in der Gründung ihrer ARIA, so haben die das genannt, ist.
Die wir auch schon lange beraten, wie sie es tun sollen.
Aber auch in Frankreich, in Italien etc. gibt es ähnliche Initiativen.
So das finden wir gut, wir teilen da, also so im Sinne der Creative Commons können die alles von uns haben,
was wir erfunden haben, gefunden haben für uns und wie es geht und wie wir uns strukturiert haben und was man da machen kann.
Auf der EU-Ebene gibt es das European Innovation Council, das EIC, was auch natürlich viel breitbandiger
und höher standardisiert zumindest mal Innovationsprojekte finanziert, das ist nicht unbedingt Sprunginnovation immer,
aber es ist schon viel Geld.
Du kannst da aus einem Programm 2,5 Millionen in Zuwendungen und bis 15 Millionen in Eigenkapitalfinanzierung bekommen aus der EU.
Und da gibt es auch schon einige Projekte aus Deutschland, übrigens einer der Gewinner da auf dem Falling Walls,
die aus Bioabfällen Plastikrohstoffe machen, die haben so einen Grant bekommen.
Also da arbeiten wir natürlich sehr stark mit zusammen, weil es natürlich immer ein bisschen egal ist wo das Geld herkommt
und vielleicht sogar ein bisschen egal ist, wo in der EU das Projekt ist und die Leute sind und so.
Und wenn wir unsere Instrumente, die wir haben, zusammenlegen, können wir natürlich viel effektiver zusammenarbeiten.
Also sind wir da im ständigen Austausch und entwickeln diese Zusammenarbeit auch immer weiter.
Und wenn jetzt Frankreich sagt, wir machen jetzt auch unsere Agentur, dann wären wir gut beraten,
mit denen uns eng abzustimmen und auch gemeinsame Projekte zu machen.
Weil wir es schon zweimal erwähnt haben, sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären, Falling Walls ist eine Konferenzserie,
die in Berlin stattfindet immer am 09. November zum Mauerfall eben und da geht es worum?
Da geht es um Wissenschaft eigentlich, die die großen Fragen der Zeit löst, so habe ich es ja eben formuliert.
Also es geht immer darum, welche Wände können wir abreißen, sozusagen um neue Wege zu schaffen, um bestimmte Dinge zu tun.
Und das tun wir mit der Kraft der Wissenschaft und Forschung und Entwicklung.
Also sind wir thematisch da, glaube ich, nah dran mit der SPRIND, deswegen verwundert es wahrscheinlich auch keinen,
dass wir da Partner sind und da zusammen dran arbeiten.
Tolle Netzwerkveranstaltung.
Also wenn ihr euch das mal im Internet anschaut, wer da so alles war jetzt, das war die Crême de la Crop,
also die ganzen Biontech-Leute und die Charpentier, die CRISPR-Frau, solche Leute triffst du.
Aber du triffst auch das Geld sozusagen, die Stiftungsvertreter der großen Family Offices sind da,
viele ausländische Gäste, der ehemalige russische Bildungs- und Wissenschaftsminister war auch da
und mit den Leuten kannst du da networken und reden, das ist super spannend.
Aber gleichzeitig werden auch Preise ausgelobt, deswegen sind auch viele junge Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler da,
die sich beworben haben, das ist ein riesiger Katalog von Projekten, der da abgeackert wird.
Und denen wird da eine große Sichtbarkeit und eben Zugang zu allem möglichen, zu Netzwerk und Geld gegeben,
um ihre Projekte weiterzuentwickeln.
Also ich war mal wieder begeistert.
Was für eine Rolle spielt denn so die Stifterszene, die Stiftungen in Deutschland in diesem Innovationsbereich?
Das ist ja jetzt auch ein Segment, wo eine ganze Menge Geld verteilt wird und wo es immer sehr forschungs- und zukunftsorientiert zugehen soll,
wenngleich natürlich dann je nach Stiftung auch sehr themenfokussiert, das ist vielleicht schon mal ein erster Unterschied.
Aber ist das ein Bereich, mit dem auch zusammengearbeitet wird in irgendeiner Form?
Ja klar, du hast ja, also du hast Verbände und Stiftungen und Initiativen, die bestimmte Themen beackern,
wie du schon sagt hast, jeder hat so sein Spezialgebiet und wenn sich das mit einem Thema von uns schneidet,
arbeiten wir natürlich mit denen zusammen.
Also weiß nicht, es gibt ja eine dena, deutsche Energie, wir haben viele Energiethemen, also tauschen wir uns darüber auch aus,
und gleichen uns auch ein bisschen ab, welche Strategien wir da eigentlich haben, woran wir glauben, was wir sehen und so weiter.
Bis hin zu einfach schlicht Geld.
Also wenn eine Stiftung sagt, wir haben uns jetzt vorgenommen, ins Thema X Geld zu tun,
dann machen wir unsere Einreicher drauf aufmerksam.
Also auch wenn wir letztlich ein Projekt nicht machen, weil es vielleicht nicht genug Sprung ist für uns,
helfen wir den Leuten häufig, dann die richtigen Geldtöpfe zu finden und das können auch sehr gut Stiftungen sein.
Weil oft merkst du sofort, das passt zu denen, da müsst ihr mal da hingehen und dann machen wir die Connections
und dann können die dahin.
Also das ist schon ein tolles Ökosystem, was wir da haben, was mitkommt.
Auch umgekehrt sprechen uns natürlich die Stiftungen an und sagen, können wir nicht was gemeinsam machen.
Also wir sind hier, was weiß ich, Bildungsmission oder wie können wir mehr Ausgründungen in den Unis machen oder so.
Und über diese Themen unterhalten wir uns mit all denen, um eine Zusammenarbeit zu machen,
um vielleicht solche Themenkomplexe einfach gemeinsam anzugehen.
Und wenn es erst mal nur so ein Netzwerkknoten ist in diesem ganzen Fragestellungswald.
Genau.
Um einfach die richtigen Leute zusammenzubringen.
Ja super, das bringt mich so ein bisschen an das Ende meiner Fragen, die ich so gehabt habe und auf die ich so gekommen bin.
Was gibt es denn noch so in der Zukunft, was wir vielleicht noch nicht tangiert haben, auf das man seinen Blick noch richten sollte?
Boah es gibt so viele Themen.
Ich glaube, vielleicht eins, was mich doch sehr bewegt, das ist die unseres Zukunftsnarratives.
Vielleicht können wir da noch mal drüber reden.
Wie stellen wir uns die Zukunft vor, was erzählen wir darüber eigentlich?
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, dass wir eigentlich sehr pessimistische Zukunftsvorhersagen haben.
Also die Welt geht eigentlich reihenweise unter und wenn die Umwelt uns nicht killt und die Erde kaputt geht,
dann sind es halt die Immigranten oder irgendwas anderes oder Pandemien.
Das sind schon Themen, die wir da unseren Kindern aufladen, dass die dann ein bisschen neurotisch werden und ausrasten,
das kann man ja wirklich verstehen, das ist einfach nicht gut.
Jetzt kann man das aber auch umdrehen und sagen, das sind die Herausforderungen unserer Zeit,
die wir mit unserem Wissen und Köpfen lösen können und das ist ja auch eine Chance.
Da tun sich ja Gelegenheiten, Chancen auf, was zu machen, was es jetzt noch nicht gibt.
Ich finde, diese Geschichte müssen wir besser erzählen.
Es gab ja mal zukunftsoptimistische Zeiten, als man hier donut-shaped space stations gemalt hat und so was, so 70er Jahre oder so.
Ja und auch noch so überhaupt im letzten Jahrhundert, da war ja das Jahr 2000 war ja so der Inbegriff der Zukunft.
Genau, alles hieß auch irgendwie 2000, das war weil 2000 war irgendwie das Ding.
Bis dann die Negativprognosen kamen, so Club of Rome und so weiter, wie die Welt jetzt untergeht.
Die Untergangspropheten haben übrigens nie recht gehabt, sind aber trotzdem noch gut im Business.
Also wir sind ja mal noch da, noch nicht zugefroren oder erschwitzt oder so.
Womit ich nicht sagen will, dass wir die Probleme nicht ernst nehmen sollen, unbedingt,
aber weil ich sage mal so, die Mutter aller Sprunginnovation ist saubere Energie so billig, dass man sie nicht mehr abrechnen braucht.
Damit löst du schon mal einen ganzen Sack anderer Probleme.
So dann haben wir noch übrigens auch ein Ernährungsproblem, ein Wasserproblem, ein Luftproblem,
das würdest du alles damit lösen.
Zweite große Erfindung muss natürlich im gesundheitlichen Raum stattfinden,
also wenn wir das Altern als Krankheit heilen können, dann hast du auch einen ganzen Sack Probleme auf einmal gelöst.
Wenn man das als Ziel nimmt, wenn man sagt, das müssen wir doch schaffen, wir sind doch schlau
und wir leben ja auch gerade in einer Infrastruktur, in der man solche Erfindungen machen kann,
dann sieht die Zukunft plötzlich ganz anders aus.
Und dann brauchen wir auch nicht über Verzicht reden oder über weniger Menschen auf der Erde.
Es ist ja schon fast auch ein bisschen zynisch zu sagen, okay ich trinke jetzt nur noch Hafermilch-Cappuccinos in Berlin,
habe auf Milch verzichtet, man bin ich ein toller Hecht.
Das ist super arrogant, also damit wird die Welt mal so gar nicht geheilt.
Denn die Leute, denen sich die Frage nicht stellt, die geben da einen Scheiß drauf.
Ist aber lecker.
Ist lecker, nein, ich bin auf Hafermilch umgestiegen und fühle mich auch als Weltretter, auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich möchte niemandem vorschreiben, dass alle Hafermilch trinken müssen.
Klar.
Das sollten wir denen schon überlassen.
Wenn wir aber diesen Wohlstand durch diese Sprunginnovationen, die ich gerade genannt habe, für alle schaffen,
das Migrationsproblem löst du dann natürlich auch, weil du bringst ja dann den Wohlstand in alle Ecken,
dann kann eine Welt auch viele Menschen tragen, auch zehn Milliarden, die wir wahrscheinlich werden werden.
Und wenn alle wohlständig sind, dann wird sowieso die Weltbevölkerung schrumpfen,
das kannst du in den Industrienationen ja sehen, wie das funktioniert.
Also würde ich sagen, lasst uns doch mal den Blick nach vorne richten, lasst uns mal positiv sein und sagen,
welche großen Fragen gehen wir jetzt an und dann arbeiten wir alle dran, das zu tun.
Also diesen Spirit mal zu drehen und unseren Kindern eine Zukunftsvision zu geben, die auch erstrebenswert ist
und sie zu motivieren, da reinzugehen, ist, glaube ich, mindestens genauso wichtig wie alles, was wir bis jetzt besprochen haben.
Ja, so eine mentale Wende an der Stelle ist, glaube ich, ganz hilfreich, weil irgendwann ist es dann auch zu viel mit Doomsday.
Ja, das Glas muss wieder halbvoll sein sozusagen.
Genau.
Ja, das kann ich nur unterstützen.
Trotzdem würde ich sagen, dann sind wir jetzt hier erst mal fertig.
Vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu Sprunginnovationen und anderen Überlegungen
und was wir mit unserer Zukunft eigentlich so anstellen sollten.
Ich sage auch, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.